はい それではよろしくお願い致します
今日はあの ちょっと集まりが少ないのは雨が降ってるからだろうとか思いましたけど
そうではなくて おそらく私に騙されて欲しくないと
今日はやめますということになった可能性はあります
今日のテーマは この騙されない生き方という
嘘に踊られず 疑心暗鬼にもならない方法という
宣伝文句にあるほど派手にはやりませんですけどね
宣伝は宣伝ですから 結構騙されるように書きます
実際はそんなに面白くないんです
それで最初に疑問 騙されたくないですか？というね
これって当然な気持ちなんですね
しかし 我々は騙されたくはないんだけど
人を平気で騙せますね
これ誰でもやってます
すごい調子のいい希望ですね
私はあなた方を騙せますけど
あなた方は私を騙すなよというのは人間の普通の気持ちなんです
人っていうのは他人を騙すプロなんです
皆様も結構見事なプロなんです
騙すことをね 他のことはちょっとわかりませんだけど
人を騙すことになったら
もうプロでない人っていうのはいないんです
何を隠そう 動物さえも他人を騙すことにチャレンジするんです
動物はものすごい結構頑張ってますよ
皆様にはね なかなか自然との付き合いで生活するチャンスがないんだけどね
自然の中で生きてみてください
見事にいろんなからくりするんですね
動物同士でも騙し合いやってるし
人間と関わり持っちゃうと結構人間を騙すんです
あの 普通に言えば このまあ皆様知ってますね
キャモフラージュというね
あれで生まれつき騙し騙し屋のプロでしょうに
動物は小さいんだからってことじゃないんですよ
タコみたいな頭がいい動物はね
いろいろ色を変えて形を変えてキャモフラージュするのはわかりますけど
この昆虫 ものすごい もう見事に騙すんですよ
あの枯れた葉っぱのように形の昆虫あるでしょ
人間の目にも見えませんよ
じーっと見て あの ちょっとなんかいじってみない限りは
それから枝の形取ってる昆虫いるでしょうに
まるっきり見えませんね
それで私がこの蝉が鳴いてると
もういくら見ても私の目には見えないんですね
そうすると私はどこかのちっちゃなもう若い男の子なんかがいたら
あの蝉はどこにいるのかい？と聞いちゃうと
若い連中には結構目が見えますから
あっちあっちだよとね
言うんだけど どこどこですかと
この 1年前かな ね かなり時間かかったんですね
で この若者はもうこちらでしょうにとかね
言っても言っても見えないんだから
私は一つの枝 枝を一つ取って
もうこうやってさして見せたところで見えたんです
ここだよと やっぱり蝉が木の幹に止まってもう鳴くんだけど
見えない あれほど音を出してるのに
あれほどすごい音を出してるのに見えない
だから他の鳥たちにも見えないでしょ
だからそれって俺がこちらにいないんだよという騙しでしょ
はい その騙しはまああの身を守るためのものだからね
もう悪いやつやっていうことはちょっと言いづらいんですね
犬猫はどうですかね 相当騙されてるでしょ
で このカラスとか  うん
あれやこれやと工夫してね
まあそれまた皆様に経験ないかもしれません
自分の国はもうカラスはいつでも人間と一緒に生活しているんだからね
まあ人間の食べ物を狙うことに決めたら
見事にそこを何とかして取っていくんですね
まあまずそこら辺にいるんですね
何のこともなく 私は興味もないんだと
こんなあなた方の食べ物にはという感じでいて
こちらなんか別なことに気が行くまで待っていて
ちょっと気が変わったなと瞬間にも持っていっている
だからそれでもまんまとカラスに騙されるということになります
そういうことで この相手を騙すということはね
人間に限った能力だけではなくてね
まあ動物たちにもあることはあります
もし他人が騙すことしかしないならば
私は騙されてない 気をつけていますと言えないはずです
まあ一応一応あのややこしい文章ですけどね
だから私は私は騙されませんよと
ちゃんと気をつけますよという
本当ですか？という話なんです
だって世界はすべての生命が私を騙そうとしているんだからね
それは見てみろ 騙せませんよと
騙されませんよと 私はきちっと気をつけますよと言えますかと
こんなのはありえないでしょう
誰と喋ったっても 犬とちょっと仲良くしたっても
向こうはもう必死で騙そうとしてるんだから
ということは まあこちらがまあ気が緩んだ瞬間にあ
可愛いとかね あれやこれやとか自分の気持ち出すでしょうね
もうとっくに騙されちゃったんです
それでもう騙されているんです
ということで 何言いたいんですかね
生命は他を騙そうとしてるんです
私たちは騙されたくないと思ってるんだけど
無駄だと 見事に騙されてますよと
でないと この世の中っていうのはものすごくややこしくなるんです
それなりに我々はね まあ無事平和で生きてるでしょ
それで動物たちとも まあそれなりに
えーと まあ仲良くしてるでしょう
あれ 平和でも調和でも何でもないんです
ただ騙す騙される で これ見事に言ってるだけなんです
騙すことと騙されることがぴったしはめたら
それは どちらでぶつかりませんね
そこで全然ぶつかりません
ぴったしはめてますね
それは我々は平和とか調和とかね
いろいろ言葉で言葉使ってますね
あれも騙されてるんです
これ平和ですか？と だから平和についてもかなり昔ね
まあ今考古学的な歴史になってるかもしれませんだけど
あの講演やりましたからね
平和って何なのかと そこで本を出した時は
平和のなんとか撲滅とかなんとかというタイトルにしたんですね
だから 私のポイントは
そんなの世の中でないんだよということなんです
ただ歌ってるだけだと
だから私たちはもう平和で調和で
もう仲良くして頑張ってますよとは言うんだけど
ああいう言葉 このちょっとした
そういうキャモフラージュした言葉を使ってますね
それも一つの騙される
騙し事の一つなんですね
そういうわけで みんな騙されてます
みんなで皆様だけじゃないんです
みんなもう生命は だって釣りやってる方々はね
魚をまんまと騙してるでしょうに
それで魚は釣り 餌は食っちゃったら万々歳ですごい気持ちいいでしょうに
だから騙す人と騙されることが組み合わせたら気分がいいんですね
これで4時間も待ってても
魚1匹もあの針を食わなかったら気分が悪いこと
気は空いてないとかね
運が悪いとかね クタクタ疲れたとかね
えらい精神的にストレス溜まってしまいますよ
そこで釣り竿を投げたところで
もう 2 3分でかかったら
また投げたらまたもう 2 3分でかかったら
まあ楽しいこと で そこで覚えておいてください
騙す側と騙される側がうまくいっちゃうと
そこで我々は平和や調和やとかね
言ってるだけの話なんです
はい 次のこのスライドごとに今日はテーマが違います
後で同じテーマを続く場合は同じタイトルにします
あの 仏教っていうのは
この人を騙すっていうことはすごい明確にスタディはしています
で 今日は紹介しません
で 紹介すると思ったらまた悪い顔をするんだからね
で 一つはこの 調べるとかなり膨大な量にもなることもありますし
あの まあそれほど誰もそこら辺整理整頓してもないんだから
私はもうずっともう片っ端から調べて研究しなくちゃいけないことになりましてね
スライド書き始めるのは大体夜10時ですから
その時間で研究を全部終わって文章も書くっていうのはちょっと時間的には無理です
で そういうわけで まあいくつか
この特にあの仏道に入っている人々にとっては
ものすごい厳しく禁止しているんです
騙すことそこであの あまりあの戒律項目には入れてないんです
あるんだけど それほど戒律項目として入れてないんだ
なぜかというと 人間っていうのはものすごい騙しのプロだから
戒律で決めたら文字通りに守る
その精神には入りません
だって守っているんではないかと
それでは何の意味もないんです
だからこの法律項目みたいな感じで
まあ昔ね もうお釈迦様がね
坊主同士で殴り合うなよと
喧嘩するな ある若い ある乱暴なグループがいて
もう若者を殴っちゃったんですね
それでこの人々はもう怖くなっちゃって
泣き出しちゃったんです
もう出家に泣くのは情けないんだから
なんで泣く？泣いてるのかって
殴られましたと だからお釈迦様
さっさと戒律ここを決めますね
出家は出家を殴ってはならんと
それでもこのいたずらグループはもう
言われたんだからそれっきり殴らなかったんです
よくできたグループでしょ？違います
それでまた行って 凶暴に悪口言って
きつい言葉言って てめえは殴ってやるぞと言って
ものすごく殴るように手を挙げて殴らないんです
そう手挙げて殴ろうと言って
もう顔のところに来たところで手を止めるんです
で 殴ってないでしょ だからあのグループはあの若者を脅したいんですね
脅して自分と若者たちがもう座っているところ
寝ているところ その場所を奪うんです
まあ自分たちで別な場所にいればいいんだけども
なんかあれ面白かったでしょうね
誰かの場所を脅して奪った方が面白いと
で そのグループはそれずっとやってるんですね
それでまたあの若者たちがまた怖くなって泣き出しちゃって
それでお釈迦様がまた新しく脅してもならないと
また新しい戒律項目作る羽目になったんですね
そこでわかるでしょ 戒律項目作っても
人間をうまく育てることはできないんです
もう騙し屋だから それで形で守るんですね
だからお釈迦様に必要なのは
人に対して心を優しく協力して
もういたわり合って もう心配し合って
もう慈しみの生き方を育ててほしいんです
精神的に これだから これやる中で
あれやる中でと規則を決めちゃうと
あの目的から目的に達することはできなくなっちゃうんです
そういうふうに この戒律にはそういうちょっとした
あの うまくいかないっていうことがね
あります 世の中もそうでしょ
世の中も法律だらけですけど
犯罪はそのままなんですね
法律あるから犯罪減ったっていうことは全くないんです
どんな国でも あ あの国はそれほど犯罪が起こりません
なぜって聞かれても 法律はしっかりしていますから
と これはありえないんです
どんな国でも法律はしっかりしています
ちょっとしたことをしたらね
中国だったらもう死刑ですからね
例えば政府の公のお金をごまかったりとかね
賄賂を取ったりすると
もう本当は死刑なんです
が 世界一賄賂は堂々とやっているのはどこかというと中国なんですね
公の人々にお金あげなかったら
何一つもやってくれないんです
しかし もらったら死刑ですけど
で 日本でも賄賂はいけないとあるでしょ
賄賂はもう 1億円取ったって死刑にならないでしょ
しかし 日本ではそんなに大げさな問題ではありません
中国と比較にならないほど少ないんですね
あれは法律のおかげですかね
違うでしょ ですから このしっかりした法治国家なんだらかんだうるさいことを言うなよと
あんなのは嘘 嘘ばっかりで
法律でおかげで国は平和でいるぞ
それさえも騙しなんです
騙されているんです ぐちゃぐちゃ法律作る連中に
法律を作ったっても何の意味もないんです
例えば飲酒運転というのは法律違反でしょ
それでビシッと警察を調べるでしょ
機械やらいろいろあって
だから日本人は一人もね
飲酒運転しないね だって法律をしっかりしていますから
まあそんなもんなんですよ
世の中は だから戒律も法律ですから
この問題はやっぱりあります
しかし 戒律は法律よりはかっこいいんです
法律を守るためには裁判制度が必要です
警察は必要です いわゆる凶暴な組織が必要ですね
体罰が必要ですね 体罰と罰金などなど
戒律はそういうものは何もなく
ちゃんと設定しているんです
ですから 戒律の方がもうかなりもう進んでますけど
完璧じゃないんですよ
人間の心育てる場合は
そういうわけで なんか余計な話たくさん喋りましたけど
あの で いろんな経典で
いろんなところでお釈迦様がこの話すんですね
この騙しの汚さという
だから普通に喋った方がものすごいインパクト強いんです
で 出家にはね どれほど厳しいかというと
このまず この衣や食べ物やら住むところやらね
これはお布施で賄っているでしょ
だから贅沢は禁止ですけど
生命 命を守るために必要な
この基本的なところ どこかで体を寄せておくところとかね
何か体を隠すためのちょっとした服とかは
まあ 1 日 1回ぐらいだけでも
1 食だけでも 食べ物っていうのはもう欠かせないんですね
命がなくなるんだからね
それさえもお布施なんですね
だから誰でも人間が 明日も食べ物あった方がいいんじゃないかなという気分が生まれるんです
今日は何か食べ物をもらいましたけど
明日もらわなかったらどうしようかと
明日も生きてるんだから
それでいろいろからくりするんですね
お布施する人々にすっごい優しい
あえて何か優しい言葉をかけたり
あるいはもうこういうこと
あの 昨日そちらのお布施
あれすごく美味しかったんですよとかね
ああいう味で 私はものすごい久しぶりですよと
で 今出家して 20年ですけど
家で 家で母親が作って 1回 2
回作ってくれた覚えがありますけど
全く同じ味でしたよとかね
すごい感謝の言葉でしょ？感動するでしょ
信者さんが 禁止です あんなのは
なぜかというと そんなこともう食べたことについて言ってるんだからね
別に どうなるんですか？人間の気持ちは
そう言われると皆様どうします？もし私が言ったらね
この間あんた持ってきたあのカレーはね
やっぱり国でも何か母親が作っていたカレーと同じ味でしたよと
どうします？まんまとやられるでしょ
だからそういうことを言うなよと
間接的にでも食べ物欲しいやと暗示する
暗示するなよと そんなものは食うならば
あの真っ赤に焼いた鉄の玉食っちゃえと
それは大丈夫やと ただまあ死ぬか死ぬほどの苦しくなるだけやと
しかし だらしない人間がということになりませんよと
心汚して不幸になって地獄に落ちることはないんだよと
そこまで厳しく言うんです
ということは 我々はいろいろ利益のために人をだましていくんですね
出家にはそれは微妙にもやるなよという
だけど まだまだもうやりたい気持ちでいるんだから
管理するのは大変なんです
だから我々は歩くとき
しゃべる時 衣を着る時は
もうすごく丁寧に 人間には嫌な気分にならないようにとしなくちゃいけないんだけど
私はまあこうやってすっかり丁寧に歩くと
みんな私がもうすごい聖者だと思ってくれるだろうという企みがあったら
とんでもないことなんです
で あの これジャータカ物語なんですけど
昔 あのある村にあの山から行者が下りてきたんです
そこで その村のある人が行者を見つけて教えたんですね
そのところを作ってあげて
食べ物を持っていくんですね
山にいたんだから ものすごい苦しかったんですね
これで塩を入れている食べ物をもらうと
もう信じられない この人にとっては贅沢なんですね
で この人をまあ考えたんですね
何とかしてこの村長の機嫌
まあ気に入られるようにいれば
この村長さんがすっと私をここで泊まってもらうでしょうと思ったんです
思って  村長さんに対しては随分丁寧で
いろいろ教えてあげたり
それから自分がいかに修行する真面目な行者でしょうかっていうことはね
ずっともう言ってるんですね
実は村長さん 私はこの人としゃべるのはこの村長さんぐらいだけやと
村長さん出ていったらね
私はずっと禅定に入って修行するんですけど
それから沈黙を守ってますよと
村長さんがすっごい気分がいいんですね
この偉い聖者がね 言葉交わすときでも私だけで
それから沈黙行で頑張ってる
なんてすごい方ですかと
そういうふうにダラダラダラダラ毎日のように言われるんだから
村長さんがどうかお願いしますから
森に入らないで ずっとこちらで住んでくださいと
私はギリギリまで面倒見ますと
私が死んじゃっても 子供たちにしっかりと面倒見るように戒めておきますよと
はい そういうことで まあまあ贅沢はしていますね
それで村長さん ちょっ
もうもう何て言いますか
へそくりというか コソコソコソコソ隠れて金をいくらか貯金しちゃったんですね
誰にもバレないように
だから税金も払わないでね
金隠しちゃっても本当に意味がないんだ
あれ使えないんです 使ったらすぐバレますからね
この人はこの千両貯まったんです
千両っていうのはまあいい額ですからね
で だから昔は銀行なんかないでしょうに
だからどこかに穴を掘って
そこを隠しておかなくちゃいけないんです
穴を掘って隠すのはいいんだけど
誰かに取られたらどうしますかね
だから家の中 穴を掘って隠すと
そうするともうさらに危ないんですね
家にいる人たちのうちまでなくなっちゃうんです
この人は考えたんですね
このお金は あの行者に作っている家のところで隠しておけば
全く心配ないんだと だって何も持ってない
ただの家だけですからね
それで何かゴザとかなんとか敷いて寝てるだけでしょ
そちらに金あるよと誰も思わないんですね
家の子供たちも思わないんですね
それでその村長さんがこの金を持っていて
家の中で穴を掘って そこを置いといてきれいにして
あの先生には全然関係ないんですけど
私の財産だからね 泥棒に取られないようにしなくちゃいけないんですよと
だから構いませんでしょうにと言ったら
そうそうそう 私にはそんなことを言う必要ないでしょうとかね
あなたの場所だから どうぞ好きなようにしてくださいと
私には全く関係ないんだと
って言うんですね さらに信頼して
また日にち経つと この人はね
千両っていうのはね すごい大金ですね
普通の人間にはね 絶対もう貯金したっても
せいぜい 1両 2両ぐらいですからね
これ現代的に言えばね
何億にもなりますからね
これぐらい金があったらね
立派なね お城を作って
死ぬまでまあ女性たちと遊んだりしてね
贅沢に生きていられるんですけどねと考えているんですね
で 初めからこいつは騙し屋でしたからね
こんなにね ちょこちょこっと食べ物じゃなくて
無茶ごちそうを食べるのにとかね
この人はこれはもう盗むことにしたんです
自分の住んでる家の中にあるものだからね
言って まあ決めた 決めたからもう村長さんが来るたびに
私は結構長い間お世話になってますねとか
今何年も経ってますよと
ずっと 別にそれ別にそれでありがたいでしょうというと
まあそれは私も楽なんですけど
でも私の修行はどうなるんですかね
修行者はね そんな贅沢に生きていかせてもらっていいとは
ちょっとなんか不安ですよとかね
やっぱり森に入って苦行しないと
なんか気が済まないとかね
毎日のようにまた森に入りたいと
また苦行に入りたいということを言うんですね
村長さんが断ります そこでまたもうもう決めましたと
村長さんに申し訳ないんだけど
やっぱり行者だからね
自分の修行やらないとね
良くないでしょうにと
だから明日 来ないでくださいと
明日は日の出とともに私はもう出て行きます
どこに行くかとも それは報告することはできませんと
村長さんが泣きながら家に帰りましたけど
明日も日の出に出て行きますからね
村長さんが食べ物を持っていくこともなく
もう諦めて悲しくているんですね
そこで まあ昼間になるちょっと前に
この人 さっさささっと
すごい早い足でまた来るんです
汗びっしょり ただびっくりして
なんで？なんで先生は
あの 気が変わったんですかね
それはよかった いえ そうではありませんと
この私のターバンに 藁一本ついていたんだと
この藁は百合の藁ですよと
持っていってはいけませんと
これ戻しに来ましたと
あのターバンに藁一本入っちゃって
素晴らしいでしょう どれほどあの信者さんがね
感動することですかね
だから信者さん 何考えるんですかと
先生が来ないならば 私はあれを潰して燃やしますよと
藁一本っていうのは取っていったっても
これ盗みにならんよと
だって価値のないものだから
それでもこの真面目さっていうのは見事なものをやと感動するんですね
それでその行者が藁一本をお返ししてもう帰るんです
そこでこの人は午後 みんな遊んでいるところに行って
泣きながらこの行者の素晴らしさを言うんですね
言ったら そこら辺でもう言うこと聞かない
もう乱暴な若者がいたんですね
まああまり信仰もないし
いい加減生活しているんですね
言ったらこの人はね あのね
私はね あの村長さんに聞きたいんだけど
村長さん なんかあの行者
すごい信頼していたりなかったんですかね
何よ ものすごく信頼してますよと
あ そう あんた何か預かってないんですかね
こういう行者にはと 財産とか
あ そういえば私はね やっぱり私のお金をね
そちらでまあ隠しておきましたけど
もうそれから取らなくちゃいけない
あ そう ではすぐ行ってみてくださいと
あなたの金は 1個もないと思いますよと
怒って このお前ら信仰もない
この若者たちがね もう行者たちをバカにしたりして
何のことをするんですかと
どこに行くつもりですかと
死んでからはとかね 怒りながら怒りながら
まあまあでは一緒に行きましょうよと
一緒に行ったんですね
行って開けてみたら金はないんですね
言ったら若者はね そういうことでしょうにと
もう飛行機で行くわけじゃないんだからね
だから我々若者 若者同士で行っちゃえばね
馬に乗ったりとかね そいつを見つかりますよと
言って追っかけて行って脅してもうたら金を取り戻しちゃったんです
はい これがジャータカ物語で
あの乱暴な若者は菩薩なんです
ということは 仏教はそんなに変な信仰とかないんです
えらい論理的なんです
で だから が人を騙ったことについてお釈迦様が語られた物語なんですね
だから詐欺師に限って
ものすごいあれやこれやと工夫して人を騙すんですね
だから仏教はそういうストーリーは結構あります
で もうお釈迦様叱責するときは
この騙し事にはものすごい気持ち悪くなるほどきつい言葉まで使うんですね
そういうわけで この仏教の世界では
このすごい厳しいことなんですね
人を騙すっていうことはね
生命を騙すっていうことはね
世の中ではないんです
まあちょっと脱線しましたけど
で それから理論的なところに入ってみましょう
なぜ他人を騙す はい これからこの人のことじゃなくて
自分のことを語ってきます
これは仏教の教え方なんです
正義の味方っていうのは仏教でないんです
あれは邪道です 皆さんも子供たちに正義の味方になることを教えるでしょ
どういうことで地獄に行く道を教えているんです
正義の味方なんかはどうでもいいんですね
この邪道は 自分がいい人間になりなさい
それで話は終了 終わり
人のことは放っておきなさいと
人が悪いんだからしょうがないだろうとか
みんなやってるんだからしょうがないだろうとか
そんな話 仏教でないんです
みんな悪いことをしたんだから
私もやってます 言ったっても
悪いことに悪い結果ないんですかね
みんなやってるんだから
あんたは無罪だとか ありえないでしょうね
だから仏教は人のことを放っておきなさいよ
自分がいい人間になりなさいということで
そのポイントで 今からね
なぜ私が人を騙すのかということを説明していきます
騙されないではないんです
騙せないということで
もうテーマを変えます
約束違反ですけどね 皆様
騙されないような生き方学びたかったんですけどね
それで騙さない生き方を学んで帰る羽目になります
で それがはっきり言えば自分の利益のためなんですね
あの利益っていうのは金だけじゃないんですね
それを覚えてください
まあ言葉ないんですから
そういう言葉使いますけど
もう自分の利益のため
利益ってお金だけじゃなくてね
いろいろ利益があります
そのために人を騙すんですよ
他を騙すことが自分にとって有意義だと思っているんです
だから自分の利益ですから
よく笑ってください そうするとあなたの店にお客さんがたくさん来ますよと言ったら
笑いたくないのにニコニコ笑っちゃう
騙しでしょう 店の看板にもニコニコ帝とかつけたらね
あちら一応ラーメン屋さんがあるでしょ
日本一美味しいラーメン屋さん結構いますよ
絶対行ってはいけませんよ
むちゃまずいと思います
ですから 食べられるぐらいの味に作りますと看板書いたらどうですかね
もう太郎のラーメンとかね
まあ頑張って食べられるぐらい
もう食べられる程度に頑張って作りますと行ったら美味しいと思いますよ
この人が一生懸命頑張ってるんだからね
これ日本一ラーメン売ってますからね
そういうわけで この自分が賢く頭使ってると思ってるんです
丁寧に挨拶することで
ものすごい力出して 声でありがとうございますとかいうことで
またいらしてくださいとか
で 気持ちが入っているかよくわかりますよ
気持ちが入ってお客さんに気に
お客さんのことを気に入って
金ではなくて で また来てほしいという場合はわかりますよ
そういうことで 私たちは他を騙すという生き方がすごく有意義な生き方だと思っているんですね
それこそ賢い 正しい生き方であると
ですから 意図的にも無意識的にも
人は他を騙し続けるんです
意図的にも騙すし 無意識的にも騙すんです
自分の利益のみを考えることはエゴであり
自我なのです それで自分の利益
自分の幸福 自分のためばっかり考えるということは
もう当然エゴですね あるいは自我ということになるんですね
したがって 自我意識がある限り人は信頼できないんです
それで結論 自我意識があるんだったら
もう信頼できないんです
はい 次 別なテーマ 慈悲とパリ
利他というね 慈悲という単語を使うことさえもしないんですよ
皆様は日常使わないでしょ？利他っていうのはよく知ってますね
誇らしげに利他を謳ってます
どれほどインチキ野郎と思うかというとね
人間っていうのは 私は日本に来た時はもう当然日本の伝統的な大乗仏教が攻撃態勢を取りましたからね
これは別にあえて悪いではなくて
日本人っていうのは人をいじめるの好きなんです
すっごく行儀が良くて
丁寧で そういう立派な世界でね
人間だと看板かけてますから
もうかなりいじめるんですよ
例えば福島で避難している子供たち
学校に行ったら 新しい学校にもみんなそこから離れて別なところに座るとかね
近寄るなよと言うんだそうです
で あるいは世界一科学者たちだからね
親たちはね 福島から来た子供たちの空気触れただけでも
自分たちが被爆すると思ってるでしょうね
結構頭がいいんです と言いながら
今日は被爆桜を なくなるんだから
もう 60年も経ってるんだからね
もう日本中なんとかして
沖縄から北海道までに植えておかなくちゃいけない
まだ頑張ってるんです
広島原爆で被爆を受けた桜って
だからすぐすぐ全部跡形もなく潰しちゃえばいいでしょうに
福島から避難している子供たちをそうやっていじめるというね
まあそこはもうそういう現象ですから
私は別にああそうかいということで終わりますけど
まあだから私にもいろいろある
私はニコニコと別にそんなこと気にしなかったんですけど
で 私によく言われたことっていうのは
この利他という言葉一つなんですね
大乗仏教っていうのは
これ利他行で頑張っています
あんた方は自分のことしか考えてないだろうとかね
私は何ともあまり日本語も喋れなかったしね
で 何と言えないで そのうち待っていろと
そのうち待っていろということで
まあ全然何ともことなく
じわじわじわじわじわとみんなと仲良くして
まあみんなみんな私のことを面倒見てくれるところまで
一応自分一人で頑張りましたけどね
しかし 言われたことには倍にして返すことはします
今やっているのはそれなんです
はい 誇らしげにこの利他を謳うでしょ
これはとんでもない騙しなんです
騙してます 大乗仏教はね
大乗仏教 世界ね 全体的に利他利他と言うんだけど
実際何やっていますかね
人々のために 葬式やら祈祷やら迷信ばっかし
ばらまいているだけでしょう
遺体の遺体の前に拝んだりとか
遺体を拝んだから生命が助かりますかね
それで私に反論は 大乗仏教お坊さんたちは今被災地なんかで行ってボランティアやってますではないかと
そんなのは当たり前でしょうに
人が困っていると宗教関係ないでしょう
宗教も民族も何も関係ないでしょうに
困っているところは助けるべきなんですよ
それでもって立派やと言われたい
言ってほしいんですかね
それって別に常識なんです
それで昨日インターネットの写真見て
それにはちょっと笑っちゃったんですけど
あの仙台の方で あの教会も全部潰れましたからね
教会の信者さんたちがさっさと集めて
この柱だけ立てて十字架を入れておいたと
だから十字架だけ 今全部もうがれきばっかしですけどね
だけ立ってますけどね
それでみんな集めて この神様にお祈りしたんだと
それでみんなに希望の光を与えているんだと
いい加減にしろよって気分になったんですけどね
だってキリスト教は正しければ
地震起こったのも津波起こったのは神でしょうに
神のに知らず起こるはずがないでしょうに
だからあいつにこれほど人々を殺されて
これほど損害を与えて
また希望の光って何ですかね
また来るぞっていうことでしょ
でも論理的に考えればね
ほら どうだいと また来るぞという脅し以外何ともないんです
だからその点で日本のお坊さんたちはね
宗教を教えることも何のこともなく
あの一応日本で亡くなった人のことを悩んでる
ではお経してあげますとかね
もうそこはただでお経をあげたりして
またボランティアやったり
若者とか体力もありますからね
頑張ってますけど その方がすごい立派なんです
比較すると この際 自分の教えを広げようということ
これはやらないんですね
やっぱり他宗教はやっちゃいますね
まあそこはいいんだけど
ただお坊さんたちがボランティアするんだということで
もうすごいというふうに褒める必要もないんです
それっていうのも常識的なことなんですね
宗教がない人もやっていることだからね
それは特別な能力 特別に優しいということになかなかならないんですね
まあケースバイケースでなる場合もあるかもしれませんだけど
一般論ですからね 一般論でいちいち調べてみると
やっぱりさすがすごいなと言えるケースはいくらでも出てくると思いますけど
まあ一般論で言えば まあ別に別にだから何ということなんです
だから私はこちらで言いたいのは
この利他利他とかね あんなことを謳っても
これはもう騙しです 人には自分の利益しか考えられないんです
こんな遺伝的にそういう能力ないんです
だから魚は歩けないでしょうに
魚には泳ぐしかできないんです
そのように生命には自分の利益しか考える能力はついてないんです
そこが生命のものすごい厳しい真理なんです
厳しくはないんだけど
聞きたくないだけなんですけどね
だましの言葉を使ってくださいということでしょ
美しい言葉 ですから このお釈迦様がこのこの粗悪語は禁止ですけど
だからといって人の機嫌を取ってしゃべることも禁止なんです
粗悪語を侮辱してそれは禁止です
しかし 人が聞きたくないか聞きたいとか
それに関わらず人の役に立つことは
たとえ厳しい言葉であっても言うべきということがブッダの立場なんです
しかし 私たちは厳しい言葉は聞きたくないんですね
それも一つの 自分が厳しい言葉を聞いときちゃったら
気持ち悪いんですね だから自分の利益知ってるんだから
いい気分になりたいんですね
それで知った人がみんないい気分になりたいんでしょうと
ですから 結構優しい美しい言葉で語ろうと思っちゃうんです
それはしません 普通 お釈迦様は
それで私も時々冗談を言ったり
いろんなことを言ったりしますけど
あれは皆様の気分を取るためじゃないんです
脳がクタクタ疲れますから
話を聞いていると 話が頭に入らなくなっちゃうんですね
それで私は脳をリラックスさせるだけなんです
ちゃんと時間見ながら
はい 今もうちょっと脳細胞に一休みあげなくちゃいけないということで
休み休みあげながら喋っているんです
だから私は平気で 2時間喋れますよ
皆様がすごい頭が良くて
だから 2時間でもへっちゃらで聞いたわけじゃないんです
どんな講演したっても
1時間になってくると
もうものすごいむちゃくちゃ苦しいんですよ
よく聞いていられません
だって 舞台とか映画にしたっても
1時間ぐらいになってくると休憩が必要でしょうに
あれ 娯楽でしょうに 娯楽でもずっと聞いているとものすごい疲れます
はい そういうことで 魚には歩けないように
生命にはね 人間だけじゃないんです
覚えてください この話は生命に普遍的な話で
生命には自分の利益しか考えられないんです
自分の利益になるならば
他人のことも考えてみることにします
だからって皆様も人のことを考えるでしょう
時々 場合によってでしょ
その時も人のことを心配することによって自分の利益になるんです
それをそれほどうまくいかないでしょ
一応 旦那のことを心配して一生懸命やっても
なんかうまくいかなくて喧嘩になる
で 子供のことを必死で心配して頑張っているんだけど
やっぱり親子関係こじれてて
うまくいかなくことになる
なんでそうなるんですかね？人のことを心配しているのに
なんで相手が素直にそれを受け止めないんですかね
このことなんです 人間にはそんな能力ないんです
生命にはね だから相手のことを心配する場合も
それによって自分が豊かな気分に
幸せな気分になりたいんです
だから相手にとってはえらい大きなお世話になるんです
だから あまりにも心配すると大きなお世話になってしまうんですね
だから心配すること自体も本物じゃないんです
はい それで自利と他人の区別は終わり
それからまあ 私は自利の話をします
利他の話はしません 自利っていうのは本能ですね
あ ついでに忘れました
皆様 おそらく自利の意味さえも覚えていないかもしれません
だって日本語で使わないでしょう
この単語は 本にあるだけ
自利っていうのは自分の利益を考えることですね
自利意識を心から取り除くことはほとんど不可能です
これは不可能です ほとんどという
まあ一応言葉入れましたけど
一つだけケースありますからね
取り除けますよと だからケース一つしかないんだから
まあ不可能と書いても構わない
ですから 白黒のラベルを貼っても意味がありません
だから自利がかっこ悪くて
利他がかっこいいやとかね
バカなことを言うなや
言うなよっていう話だけです
物事を知らず 偉そうなことを言ってはならんと
自利がかっこ悪くて 利他がかっこいいやと
それがかっこ悪いんです
嘘を言ってるんだから
そういうわけで 私たち一人一人が自利
自分の利益しか考えられないということがベースに
それが本能ですからね
良いとも悪いともそんな判断できません
例え話で言えば 人間が呼吸しているでしょ
かっこいい あと呼吸してますね
えらいこっちゃこれはと言えないでしょうね
そんなのはかっこいいことでも悪いことでもなく
どうしてもやることだからね
同じく自利という気持ちも
もう呼吸と同じものなんで
生きているならばもう自利思考なんです
そこはかっこ悪い 非道徳やとか思わないでください
そう思っちゃうとダメ人間になっちゃうんです
他人のために受難することを謳っている人に気をつけなければ
気を付ければ良いだけの話です
です それで私が言いたいのは
やっぱりこの受難の話は無茶人気ありますね
自分を犠牲にして 人々のために何だらかんだらやるというね
これは気をつけた方がいいです
人類のために一匹の人間が受難して死んじゃったと
まあアホ以外何でもないんですけど
それに世界がね むちゃくちゃ不幸になってますよ
大戦争起こりますからね
第二次戦争もその神に言われてやったところで
イラク戦争も今アメリカがやっている戦争も
全部神に言われてやっているんです
そういうことだから 今日よう気をつけた方がいいんです
しかし 今の状況によっても
あのちょっと違うところもありますよ
原発の場合は もう自分が被曝しても何とかしましょうという技術屋さんたちがね
自分の命を犠牲にして
でも なんとかしたいと思っているところも嘘かというと
そこはないんですね その人々は理性で考えているんですね
具体的に自分が被曝して犠牲になっても
国民が助かりますというちゃんとした結果があるんです
バカバカらしい結果じゃないんです
ちゃんと助かります あの原発する中なんかは
もうあまりにも放射能なくても
生き...入れられないぐらい残酷な状態なんです
悲惨な状態なんです 全部は壊れて壊れて
だから人は入らないぐらい高濃度の放射汚染で
しかし これからそこを 1 1 1 1 やらなくちゃいけないんです
だから結構人は犠牲になるでしょう
その場合ははっきりしていますね
こういう原因でこういう不幸な結果がある
それで私が犠牲になることで
こんな幸せな結果が出てくるという
あれは迷信でも信仰深いでも何でもないんです
厳密に合理的 それが完璧に善行為なんです
紛れもなく その場合の犠牲はもう自己犠牲とは思わないんです
思えないんです 本人にとってはすごい良いことをやっているという
この上のない充実が生まれているはずなんです
絶対ありえない 紛れものすごい稀有なチャンスなんですね
だからもう宝くじ 100枚ぐらい当たったような感じなんですね
その犠牲になる人にしたっても
だから結局は 100年生きていたってもね
つまらなくて 生きていて意味がないでしょう
なんとかやって食べて寝るだけで面白くないとか
人と喧嘩しながら しかし
その方々はあの短い時間で 200年分の生きる喜びを感じるんです
すぐ死んじゃっても だからまあ
それは道徳の中に入ります
自己犠牲は道徳に入りません
はい そういうことで この何でもこの一般論では語れないんですよ
だからケースバイケースで
一個一個スタディしてどうなるのかということを考えなくてはいけないんです
それから自利とはどのようなものかと学ぶことです
私たちは自利を捨てて利他になるんじゃなくて
自利は捨てられません
利他っていうのはよくわからない
魚が歩けないような感じで
よくわからない どうすればいいかと
魚も陸上に捨てたら飛びますけど
陸上なら泳げないと知ってますけどね
陸上は歩けばいいやと言ったって
魚それわからないんです
だから飛ぶんですけど
それは歩くことになりません
飛んだらまたドカンと落ちますから
結構怪我します はい そういうわけで
自利は本能ですから 自利って何なのかと学んでおけば安心なんです
はい 勉強していきましょう
自利と自我愛 生命に自我愛があります
死にたくないという感情は自我愛を表しています
皆様方は自我愛あることをわからないというならば
それで理解してください
自我愛があるんです 誰にしたって死にたくないでしょうね
死にたくないということは
自我愛から出てくる感情なんですね
そこで終わりませんよ
自我愛は ただ我々は死にたくないだけじゃないでしょ？楽しみたいしね
美味しいものも食べたいし
旅行もしたいしね 面白い品物を買いたいし
友達も作りたいし いろいろあるでしょ
自我愛には知識も理性も判断もいりません
これ便利な便利ですね
自我愛を作るために理性とかいらない
もう生きているものにはあるものなんです
しかし よく考えてください
自我愛はもう生まれたらあるものでですから
この自我愛のためにいろいろやってるでしょ
このやってることは決して理性で制御されてないんです
知識で管理されてないんです
だから問題が起こるんです
自我愛自体がもうもうとっくにあるものだから
あんたは理性があるんだから自我愛もありますよとはないんです
知識 能力全くない 障害を持って生まれても自我愛があるんです
重度の認知障害で生まれる認識障害で生まれる人々でも
何も喋れ 何も考えることできない
人の顔全くわからなくても自我愛はあるんです
だから自我愛のためにやっていること自体が制御されてないんですね
知識でも理性でも何でも
そこが問題なんですね
これは感情 煩悩ですね
だからそれは何かというと
感情と煩悩というんですね
ですから 無知に支配されているんです
感情っていうのは無知だから生まれるものなんですね
だから生命は無知に支配されています
だから生命には自我愛があるんです
自我愛は暴走して自利ではなく自我愛を招きますが
それに気づきません それは結論です
で かなりの内容は入ってます
この 6 行で 自我愛っていうのは本能として出てくるもので
知識は要りませんし ですから自我愛のためにやっている行動も理屈には合わないんですよ
我々 時々理屈 なんであなたそんなことをやるのかい？と
そんなこと聞いたって
相手はわからないんです
自分のやりたいんだからやっているんです
それで自我自我愛になりますよ
自我愛になっても言うことを聞いてくれないでしょ
人間は それが自利の問題なんですね
はい 次のレッスン あの大体このスライドごとにものすごい内容は違ってきます
自我愛から自己愛へと
で これで我々は頑張らなくちゃいけない
自我愛は自己愛にしなくちゃいけないんです
自我愛を理性で観察して
自己愛へ成長させるんです
だから自我愛はもうとっくにあるでしょ
そこはちょっと学んでみるんです
空いてるんだからといって放っておくんじゃなくて
何なのか これは と 学んでみるんです
学んでみることによって
自我愛が自己愛へと進むんですね
自我と自己って何が違うんですかね
具体的にはそれほど違いはないんだけど
自我愛の場合は厳しい感情が入ってますね
無知なんですね で 自己という場合は理性が入ってるんですね
人は別に変わったわけじゃないんです
自我愛の人も美味しいものは食べたいんです
自己愛の人も美味しいものは食べたいんだけど
一人には理性がなくて感情
もう一人には理性がある
それの程度の差なんです
が かなり結果が変わってきます
なぜかというと 自己愛の人はやりたいことは結果構わずやっちゃいます
酒飲み飲みまくりたかったらもうやっちゃいます
賭け事はむちゃくちゃやりたくなったらむちゃくちゃやります
麻薬でも好きに行ったら
もうとことん家を売ってでもやります
自己愛の人はもうあれで楽しいんだけど
私の状況ではやめた方がよろしいと思っちゃうんですね
私も遊びたいんだけど
家族もいるし 子供もいるし
ですから これは子供が悪い影響を受けたら困ります
ですから やめますと 例えば男がいて
ちょっとしたことで怒る
奥さんと喧嘩する で 子供が出てきたら
これってまずいな 子供たちも真似したらということで
だから怒ることは自害でしょ
わがままでしょ こんな性格しちゃうと
こんな家庭だったら 夫婦は仲が悪くて子供に悪いと思って自分を制御する
制御して幸せになる だから自分の利益を考えていますよ
自分の利益を考えています
幸せな家庭 子供たちはすくすくと育て上げて楽しくなりたいという自利があるんですが
ちょっと理性が入っちゃったんですね
そうすると 自己愛は自我愛は自己愛に微妙に変わったことなんです
意味はわかってないが
生かされているという言葉はよく使われています
意味はわかっていないと私じゃないんです
皆様がわかっていないんです
私がわかってます アホな単語やと
それは 皆様方 意味がわからない言葉をいっぱい使っているでしょ
いただきますとか おかげさまで
どうですか？このごろ体の調子は
おかげさまでよくなってますよと
あれ 何の意味？ 最近話題になっている天罰という言葉もあまり話題になっていないんですね
何の意味ですかね あれは
まあ一応日本の文化ではそういう意味がなく
意味がわかっているような気分で使うフレーズは結構あります
私たち外人だから学ばなくちゃあかんでしょ
学ぶとこの言葉どんな意味かとわからないと使えないんですね
それでもう発見するだけのことなんです
これっておかげ 生かされているということは曖昧なフレーズなんです
なぜならば主語がないでしょ
誰があなたを生かしてますかと
ないんだから これすごい曖昧なんですね
曖昧っていうのは妄想のもう賜物で
曖昧っていうのはひどい妄想を引き起こすんですね
だっていろいろ考えられますからね
私はちょくちょく遊びやりますよ
遊びですけど 時々人に聞くんですね
この生かされているってどういうこと？ちゃんと本人がえらい哲学的な説法をするんですね
こういうことで こういうことでとかね
例えばキリスト教の方だったら
生かされているということはね
偉大なるもう大変人々を慈しんでむちゃくちゃ人殺してる神様にして
それは私が入れますけどね
まあ生かされているんだよと
まあ日本人に聞いたらそれぞれで
大日如来に生かされているんだよという人もいるでしょうし
観音さんに生かされているんだよという人もいるし
阿弥陀さんのおかげで生かされているのもいろいろ
何でもいいんです それは
で なんでどんな解説も OK ですかね
正反対の解説も OK でしょう
あれは言葉初めから意味を定めていないんですね
だから我々にとっては妄想するためにはいい言葉なんですね
妄想することって自己破壊なんです
ろうそくの炎に独立することはできませんね
ろうそくに火をつけちゃうと炎がありますね
あれは炎さんに俺は独立するぞとはできませんね
家の子供たちみたいにね
18歳になってくると
私は一人で生活するぞとかね
偉そうなことを親に言うでしょ
言って仕送りもらうんですね
因縁によって支えられて成り立っています
あのろうそくって炎はね
因縁によって成り立ってますね
もう酸素が必要でしょうし
ロウが溶けなくちゃいけないし
ロウが溶けて熱でガスにならなくちゃいけないし
だから炎もそれなりに頑張ってます
ろうそくに熱を与えてガスにする
それで燃える しかし 燃えることは自分の力で起こるわけじゃないんですね
命も独立できません 支えられて成り立つ
それだけの話なんです
これを誰もわかってないんです
だから生かされているというんです
あれ 独立できない状況なんです
独立は成り立ちません
我々の命もろうそくの炎とまるっきり同じなんです
支えられてもらわないと
ガタンと終わり 死んでしまいます
で まだこれは続きになります
実体として独立した命は成り立ちませんと理解すれば
自我愛の錯覚が消えます
そこで自我愛っていうのは
俺がいるんだよという気持ちなんです
私は堂々といるんじゃないんですかね
と思ってるでしょ？しかし
生かされています いるんじゃないんです
生かされてという言葉は日本語の言葉ではなくて
原因によって絶えず支えられているろうそくの炎のような命なんです
その意味で使うならば
あの言葉正しいんです
だから生かされていますということだけは使ってはいけません
そうすると あまりにも無知な単語なんです
因縁によって生かされていると
これから言ってください
あのね 私の命 大したことはない
因縁によって生かされている命でしょうと言えば
ものすごい知識の智慧の言葉であって
ブッダの言葉です 誰にも馬鹿にされることはできません
いくらでも議論することはできます
ただ 生かされてますよと言っちゃうと馬鹿にされます
キリスト教の人にそれを言ったら
そうそうそう その通りです
だから神を信仰しなさいよと
あなたそこまでわかっているならばと言っちゃいます
因縁によって生かされていきますよ
いますよと言ったら その人は私にも教えてくださいと言うしかないんです
ですから 今日から生かされていますという言葉は使わないで
因縁によって生かされている
生かされている命だと自分で頑張って生きているわけじゃないんだよと
はい それが発見するとわかると
自我っていうのは錯覚やとわかるでしょうね
自分がいるわけないでしょうに
ちょっと一時的に成り立た成り立つ
いるじゃなくて ろうそくの炎は成り立ってるだけ
ある時間だけ そこをわかると
自我が錯覚であると発見します
それで自我愛が自分に有意義な生き方に変わってしまいます
はい それから人生はぐるっと変わるんです
自我が消えたら  生かされているロウソクの炎はそれなりに
ロウソクの炎は意識がないんだから
何も頑張ることできませんだけど
この炎には意識ありますからね
いろいろ管理できます
自己を支える原因たちに役に立つ態度
生き方をすれば 自分から自分
自ら自分も守られること
自分に有意義になることが見えてきます
もう全部アイデアが一行にまとめるのは大変ですけど
あまり日本語はね そんな文章は書きませんだけど
これ 私の脳が働いている方法なんですね
かなり大量のデータが 1個で考えちゃうんですね
そこで自我がないとわかってた人がこれ発見するんですね
いろいろ原因さんたちがこの命を支えてますよと
だから この命がこの原因さんたちの役に立つようにしていけば
自分を自ら守られてますよと
具体的な例で考えましょう
私にご飯作ってくれる人
私はもう何のことなく当たり前やと思っちゃうとダメなんです
あなたの仕事やろうとかね
うまくいかないんです
私もその人の役に立つように態度取る
そうすると その人はもう頼んでも頼まなくても喜んで料理を作ることになっちゃうんです
だから 生かされている環境を助けることが自分を守ることやと思っちゃうんですね
今まで自分の利益 自分の自利ばっかり考えてたんです
これ いきなり変わっちゃうんです
自利っていうのは 周りの生かされているものを助けることだよと
いわゆる利他が自利であると発見するんです
自利とは利他であると
これは大乗仏教はわかってないんです
自利利他っていうのは区別できないんだと
一個だと だから大乗仏教はあまり一般人には好まれませんだけど
我々は 2500年も頑張ってましたけど
もう一般仏教の人々は坊主は要りませんという一言葉は要りませんね
なぜかというと 自利利他っていうのは一個の単語であって
カットして分けることはできません
人間っていうのは首と体だよと
別々やと言える それで考えるのはもう首の上のところですからね
はい これはこの人の知識が入っている部分で
これはただの肉体でとかね
はい 首を切って別々にすれば
そんなありえない話でしょうに
一個です ですから 自我がなくなったところで
利他が自利であるとわかるんですね
その人が利他行をする
他人を助けることは決して大きな恐れになりません
互いうまく楽しく生活することになるんです
この人は他を騙しません
騙せません 騙しませんだけではなくて
騙せません 騙すのはとんでもないことでしょうね
自分を支えられている
自分の命を支えられている人々でしょうに
騙していいわけないでしょうに
これっていうのは 自分が料理を作る
作って自分が食べる そこでトマトを入れたいんだけど
料理にはトマトはない
まあトマトって赤いんだから
あ こっちは赤い紙がありますね
これを潰して入れましょうと
これ騙しでしょ これでうまくいきますかね
赤い折り紙を 3枚ぐらい潰して入れちゃう
トマトの代わりに だってトマトも赤いんだから
こんな騙しでうまくいきますかね？だって料理が私を支えているでしょうに
だから騙してはならないんです
だから私が支えられて生かされているものであるとわかった人の自我がなくなった時点で
騙すこともできなくなっちゃうんです
難しいんですね 一応簡単だと思ったんですけど
はい このセクション終わったらちょっと休憩いたします
自我愛の矛盾 あれで随分のセクション終わりました
一個一個巨大なテーマなんです
で このサミット2回のコーサラさん言ったという経典からですね
コーサラ国王 自分を大好きだと言っていても
身口意で悪行為をする人は自分自身の敵なのです
その人々は言っていることと反対のことをやっているのですと
これ コーサラ様の言葉で
原文はもっとわかりやすいんです
で 長いんだからね 人々は自分のことはむちゃくちゃ愛してますよと
自我愛がね きっびしくあるんだけど
その人々はこの自我愛のために悪い言葉を語る
言ってはいけないことを言う
やってはいけないことをやる
考えてはいけないことをやる
いわゆる罪を犯すんだと
身口意で それによってむちゃくちゃ不幸になるんだと
これは王様の 経験なんです
この王様ってすごく恐ろしい王なんですよ
非常に凶暴な政治家なんですね
だからお釈迦様と仲良くしているんですけど
悟りにも達してないんです
じりじり政治家は辞めなかったんです
だから国土を広げることなんかはむちゃくちゃやってます
で 王様に反対やった人とかね
逆らった人とか 罪を犯った人とかね
死刑決める場合は最高裁判裁判官は国王ですね
毎日裁判 そこで調べているんだから
全部有罪だと しかし 審判官には死刑という一言は言えないんです
人を殺す権利は王にしかないんです
戦以外は だからちゃんと審判を受けて
有罪 有罪 有罪で まあこれはまあ死刑の有罪でしょうというところで
王様のところにみんな放り投げるんです
だから王様って 朝例えばね
まあ9時で仕事を始めたら
もう12時半までずっと死刑
死刑 死刑 死刑 それに判子を押すだけなんです
王ってすごい面白い仕事ですね
だからいっぱい徳を積んで
来世どこかの国の王になるようにと
やっぱりお釈迦様にもそれぞれ引き合いもあるし
ものすごい面白くない仕事なの
極限に 毎日 毎日 まあ好き勝手に休めますけど
仕事をするたびに何人かを死刑にしなくちゃいけない
そこで王様はやっぱりはい
次と言ったら 何々 あと名前聞いただけで
はい 死刑 はい 次 何々さんです
はい 死刑 それはちょっとまずいんだからね
一つ聞くんです 聞いても王様にはもうもうもう審判する必要はないんです
証拠はどうですか？とか
もうとっくに調べて終わっているんです
だから王様は お前 人の家に入って家族みんな殺しちゃったんですねとかね
君は人の家に入って家族５人殺しましたねとかね
言ったら本当ですかと聞くみたいに
そしたら 王様はとんでもない
これは私をそうやってはめられただけで
私はそんなことをやっていない
どうか許してくださいと言うんだそうです
言うと王様ははい 死刑
それで終わります そこで王様は自分の気持ちは言わないんです
王様が申し訳ない 王様
私がバカで愚か者で もうついやってしまった
有罪です どうかお許しください
と言っちゃうと じゃあ１０年刑にしますとかね
王様にできます だからそれだったら罪を認めてほしくないという気持ちなんです
騙されて はい あなたは無罪にするぞと
それやりたくないね 政治家だから
これで人間がやったことはやってないと言うし
また毎日人殺したりしているんだから
自分たちがものすごい体罰を受けたり
ものすごい昔の罰っていうのは恐ろしいもんなんですよ
あのドラム缶みたいなものに人を入れて
中いっぱい釘を入れて刺して
中に人を入れて山から落とすんです
それでぐるぐるぐるぐるあれ回るんです
までドカーンと だからもう死ぬかもしれません
死なないかもしれませんだけど
死んだ方が幸せということになるんです
死刑にはしません それも一つ
だからそういうこともやらせますからね
だから王様が自分の体験で
人間が自分のことをあまりにも可愛がっていて
悪いことをするんだ だから自分の敵だと
悪行為をする人々は 体が口先で私のことは大好きやと言ったっても
あんなのは嘘やと これはお釈迦様は認めます
自我愛の矛盾について
この感想はお釈迦様も認めます
これ矛盾ですよ 自我自我の自我があるにも関わらず
自我の道を歩むでしょう
自我愛ある人は自我の道を歩むと
矛盾もいいところでしょうに
だから人類というのはいつでも自我愛の道を歩んでいますが
自我自我の道を歩んでいますが
自我愛はあります だからみんな矛盾なんです
だから自我愛は必ず矛盾を生じます
起こします ですから これは自己愛にしなくちゃいけないんです
生命の自分好きは現実です
生命はいつでも自分好きなんです
それでまたお釈迦様の言葉
サッバーディサーアヌパリガッマチェーサネーバッジャガピヤタラマッタマッタナコチ
エワンピヨプトゥアッターパレーサンタスマーナヒンセパラマッタカーモ
四方八方 どこを調べても自分に勝る好きな人は見えず
どこを見ても一番好きなのは自分のことなんです
生命には自己がそれほど好きです
生命には自分ですね 自己というの場合
自分というものはそれほど好きなんです
四方八方 どこにも存在もしない
自分より可愛いものは
自己を好きなら他に害を与えないこと
というブッダの言葉なんです
なぜならば 自己っていうのは支えられているんです
自分を 命はあらゆる原因で因縁で
その中で生命も入っています
だから害を与えないことやと
これはもう断言的にダメなんです
いかなる場合でも はい
それでちょっと休憩いたしまして
次のテーマに入ります
次のテーマはもうちょっと違います
では 次のセクション始まります
はい これからまた内容がそんなに難しくないと思います
無駄な批判 あの人 この人
政治家 世界が人々を騙している
嘘をついていると勝手に言ってもね
我々はよく言う あの人は人を騙しちゃった
この人も人を騙っているとか
政治家が人を騙っているとかね
そんなことを勝手に言っても
それは無意味な行為なんです
なくなると思う？なくならないでしょうに
だったらもうあんまり無意味なことをしない方が身の安全なんです
生命たるものは人を騙すんだから
誰かを犯人に仕立てて
あの人がこの人を騙しましたよとかね
こんなのは当たり前のことで
世界は直せないものです
特に恋人に裏切れたとかね
裏切られたとか 放っておけ
そんなのは もしかすると自分にはチャンスなかったかもしれませんしね
だからこの  そんなもんなんですね
自分も他を騙しているでしょうに
まず言う批判する権利さえもないんですね
自分も堂々とやっているんだからね
一人一人が堂々とやっていて
騙されるのは嫌で そんなことを言ってるんですね
騙すならば騙されることもしょうがないでしょうに
お互い様でしょう だからそこはすごい屁理屈なんですね
世の人間は他人を批判することで正義かぶりをしているんですね
それはなおさら汚いんですね
ギャーギャーギャーギャー評論家になって
批判することになって
知識人になって あれも悪い
これも悪い言ってて なんかその人すごいかっこいい人間のように見えちゃいますね
ね 政治の世界でも雇になったら
まあ精密に もうもうありこともないことも言いながら批判すること
自分たちが政権取ったらもっとダサいですけど
それでえらいもう先生善人かぶりですね
これすごい気持ち悪いんです
だからあの人悪い この人悪い
こんなこと言ってね あんた知ってる？とかね
あの人こういうことしましたよとかね
よく気をつけた方がいいんだよとかね
あれ自体ものすごい気持ち悪いこと
普通人を騙すことはどうったことない
それは白黒は言えません
白黒なりたつものじゃないんです
私たちは相手の機嫌を取っておかなきゃ
自分の都合はうまくいかないでしょうに
だからそれなりにまあ騙して生きてますよ
その上こんなこと言っちゃうと
もうかっこ悪いももう切りがないんです
自分が他を騙すことをやめれば良い
だから我々にできることが
世間を批判して クタクタ疲れて
世間に嫌われて追い出された荷物にも
ガラクタ 生ゴミになるんじゃなくて
自分がギリギリまで人を騙さないことにする
それでも騙したくないと思うならば
自我自我愛を自己愛に変えることですね
そうすると騙さない人間になりますね
それで自分がとても美しい
素晴らしい良い人間になっているんです
騙されて損する この騙されることは嫌がるのは損するんだからなんですね
相手が利益を求めて騙すので
損するのは当たり前のことです
騙す場合は 騙す側が自分の利益を考えていますね
だから騙される側が当然損します
しかし なぜ騙されるのでしょうか
と これって知ってるでしょうに
人がもう騙そうとしているんでしょうに
でもまた騙されるでしょうに
あれってなんですかね
だから私のポイントは
もう騙すのは世間の常識なんですね
騙されるセクションがなんとか管理できるはずなんです
まあ普通日本語でも言うでしょ
騙された側が悪いというね
人の話に乗ったところで自分が得するという錯覚があったからなんです
自分がこの話に乗ったら得するんだよと錯覚を起こしちゃったんです
人は私に得させるために話しかけてくれませんよ
で 人の話を聞いて あ この人の話に乗っちゃえば結構得しますねとかね
自分が変な錯覚を起こしちゃったんです
自分の利益に目がくらんで客観性を失ったからですね
そこで人が喋っていると
自分の客観性を失ってしまって
相手の話にどんどん乗っていくのは
常に客観的に理性で聞かなくちゃいけないということが忘れちゃったんです
あ これなら得するぞと
あのテレビショッピングでやってるあれ見るとね
よく見えるでしょ で これでこのものを買って食べれば
もう体重がもう 10キロ 1
週間に 10キロ減ったとかね
それで誰かの写真出すでしょ
もう凸凹の体で で それから突然もう 2週間後といって
すごいスマートな人の写真出すんですね
あり得るんですか？そんなのは
それはよくできています
あの そういうタレントさんというか
そういう人々いるんです
あの使用前の写真ばっかり撮ってもらって
金もらって 使用後の写真ばっかり撮る別の人格
人間がいるんです そこで
私たちはこの写真見たら
ああ すごいかっこいいですね
私もそんな体欲しいねと言って
すぐ買ってしまっちゃいますね
だから買ってみたら騙されたとかね
そんな違法な薬やとかね
禁止しているもので 後で分かってて訴えたりするでしょうね
あれも情けないんですね
なんで買ったんですか？っていうね
騙すのは世の仕事 騙されないのは自分の仕事
はっきり仕事を覚えておいてください
騙すのは世の中の仕事なんです
騙されないように頑張るのは自分の仕事なんですね
だから自分の責任なんですね
限りのない騙しのテクニック
次のセクションだからすごいテクニックがあるんです
生命の出現からも人を騙すことをやってきたのです
現れたというから我々これやってます
ですから 騙しのテクニックは個人の安全対策をはるかに超えています
テクニックはもう何十万年も出来上がっているんですよ
磨いて磨いて磨かれて
こっちのちっぽけな命でしょ
生まれても間もないしね 1
万年と自分の寿命は50年と比較にならんでしょうね
1万年かけて あるいは20万年かけて磨いたテクニックに太刀打ちできると思いますかね
50年の人生で 騙されないようにするのは極限に難しいですから
自分の仕事ですけど 結構難しいんです
それから嘘も先に言えば繰り返し言えば事実になるという話がありますね
これよく使ってますよ
昔から もう先に言っちゃいます
それから繰り返しちゃいます
例えばイラクのフセインが WMD 持ってるんだと
というか 大量破壊兵器ですね
証拠何もなかったんです
そうだろうと思っただけ
それで大統領が発表するんですね
それから発表は取り消せませんから
さらにさらにさらに言って
世界中にみんないえいえいえと言われて
日本もギャーギャーギャーギャーと
やっぱりこの大量破壊兵器を持ってけしからんやとかね
何より日本も持ってますけど
日本の自衛隊はピストルしか持ってないと思ってるんですかね
ピストルだったら大量破壊はできませんでしょ
日本の自衛隊もかなりもう凶暴なすごい自衛隊なんですよね
やろうと思ったらすごいと思いますよ
それなのによく言うこと
で まあそういうふうにどうなったかというと
もう嘘を言ってからもうダラダラダラダラダラダラ言うと
ああそうだということになっちゃうんですね
それで国を潰してから何もなかった
だからそれで その時そう思っていたんだから
で また開き直り だから事実になるのでは
みんなまんまと騙されただけの話です
例えばマスコミでも 何の根拠もないことは何回も繰り返して言うでしょ
もう信じちゃうんですね
特に人に人をはめはめすしたければ
マスコミはいきなりストーリーを作ってもう流すんです
これは事実だと言わない
言わないんで  そういう話がありますよと
言っても 人をインタビューして
あんたどう思う？私はそうそうだと思いますよとかね
アンケートを取ったところで
60% まあもうこれは認めますよと
もう 20%は反対やと
他はまあどちらでもないというアンケートまで
騙されるでしょ ああいう国民のなんとか意見とチャートを作ったり
あんなに嘘っていうのはね
結構テクニックがうまいんですね
もしかするとそんなの騙されないのっていうのも私だけかもしれません
おかしいかもしれません
いくらニュースで流れて
いくら CNN で言ったってもね
全然乗りません その中でどこまで事実かということはよく見えます
その事実はどんなカラクリで発表しているかっていうことも見えますけどね
はい 次 いろいろ騙しのプロを紹介します
宗教 長い文章ですけど
神や超能力や奇跡やすげや予言や
神のよこしまな行為によって行為をして子供を作ったこととかね
俺にすがらないと救われないとかね
うちの宗教でうちの神にすがらないと救われませんよとかね
この神に逆らうと地獄行き
神の力で病気を治せてみせる
商売繁盛にさせてみせる
希望 願望を叶えてみせるとかね
事実だと思う 長い間言い続けたんだから
まんまと騙されているだけです
皆 大事な話だからね 事実だから一斉に乗りましょう
乗ってるでしょうに 一欠片も証拠はある
神は人間として子供を作ってちゃ
あれよこしまな行為でしょうに
で 拝む しかし 得するのは宗教家だけです
世の中に日本でもたくさんなるでしょうに
カビみたいですね 宗教っていうのは
生えるは生えるは生えるは
どうしてもちょっと放っておいてももうもう生えて
だからものすごい宗教家の腕がいいんです
あの統一教会とか韓国にあったでしょうに
とんでもない詐欺師でしょ
でも日本も半分以上信仰しちゃったんです
それで負けるかって また作るでしょ
今はドラマブームだからね
宗教ブームじゃないんですね
韓流のドラマブームも
あれもちょっとあんまりもう品格はよく見えませんだけど
向こうは必死で頑張って作ってるんだからね
ブッダは学問的に見ても偉大なる人物です
歴史的な人物です その教えは事実にあっているか否かを調べる権利
自由を与えて 事実のみ
人の他人の役に立つことのみを語ったんです
ブッダが 微塵も騙しがないんです
調べてくださいと言うんです
逆らったら地獄に落ちるそうと
一言もないんです 二度と生まれ変われないので
私たちから何の利益も期待しなかったんです
人はなぜ騙すとかというと
ジリがあるんだからなんですね
ブッダが悟ったんだから
もうジリいらないんですね
ジリ消えちゃったんです
ジリと理とか一緒になったわけじゃないんです
消えちゃったんです だからブッダがお釈迦様は何か期待して説法しているだろうとかね
拝んでもらいたくとか
全くないんです 涅槃に入る時でも怒鳴ったんです
拝む連中を この人々じゃないんだと
私は心配しているのは
とダンマラーマってお坊さんがね
お釈迦様の最後の挨拶に行かなかったんです
行ってくださいと言ったら
私は忙しいと言うんです
そんな暇がないんだと
ったら これってお釈迦様涅槃ってことを発表してしまったから
それだったら人が死にますよと
この日にちではっきり言ってるのはたったお釈迦様だけでしょうに
それでいて最後の挨拶するのは当たり前の常識でしょうに
このお坊さんが忙しいというんです
お坊さんのくせに それで他のお坊さんたちが
これとんでもない人やと言ってお釈迦様報告したら
お釈迦様が病気で倒れていたんですけど
呼びなさいと で 呼んだんです
そしたら本当ですかねと
そしたら本当です お釈迦様
私は忙しいんですよと
こんなにこちらに来て
お釈迦様のそばにうろうろして泣いたり
そんな暇がないと いう感じですね
それでなんであんた忙しいですかと聞いたら
私はね お釈迦様は解脱に達しな
悟りなさいとずっと教えたでしょうに
私はお釈迦様が最後の息をとる前に
止める前に 何としてでも悟ってみせようと
悟ってやるぞと思って頑張ってますよ
だから時間ないんだと
お釈迦様もうそろそろ亡くなるんだから
そしたらお釈迦様はサードサードと
素晴らしい 素晴らしいと
私のことを心配してるのはこの人やと
こんな拝むわ 花持ってくるわとか泣くわとかね
うるさい以外何でもないんだと
そういうわけでお釈迦様はみっちりも塵一個だけでも何も期待してないんです
だから人を騙すことはありえないんです
理由があります もう悟ってます
もう涅槃に入ります もう二度と生まれ変われません
しかし 摩訶不思議な摩訶不思議
ブッダが生まれ変わってますね
日本で はい では信じましょう
どれほど嘘をついて人を騙しているのかと
どれほど騙されているのかと
神が奇跡を起こして 何億もいる人々の中で
たった一人を病気から治す
本当かどうか確かめる方法はありません
科学的に事実になるためには繰り返すことが必要ですが
神の奇跡は二度と繰り返されないんですね
皆そろって信じます ものは事実かというために
もう一度リピートしなきゃダメでしょ
この薬は完璧にこの病気に効くそうと言ったら
一人だけの病気が治りましたけど
それっきり 飲んでも飲んでも治らないんだったら
それはあの病気に効く薬
遠い昔 神やら何やらわからないんだけど
誰かの病気治しましたとかね
だからすごいそうと しかしリピートできないんですね
だから信じるんですね
みんな 明らかに騙しでしょ
騙しでなければ 神のパワーで次から次へと人の病気を治していくことでしょうに
事実なら 本当のことなら
だって別に神があれに脳出血に出欠あれかからないでしょ
何が脳出血を起こしちゃって倒れているんだけ
今はできませんよというならばね
それでもないというでしょう
すーっと見張ってるでしょ
なんで今何もできないんですかね
人に調べる能力が出てくると
何のことなく隠れるんですね
隠れて騙すんですね 昔はそんなことなかったら噂を信じちゃったんです
噂っていうのはいくらでも作れますから
唱えたら煩悩がなくなる
悟りに達する呪文もあります
お金払って学びましょう
あの真言系統の仏教では
怒りをなくしたければ
この呪文 何だらかんだらもう悟りたければこの呪文とかね
昔 カイニウ会館で講演があった時は
ある若いチベットの人が伝授しているんですね
呪文を だから私の講演には会費はいくらぐらいでしたっけ？当時でわかりませんだけど
あちらでは 1 万か 2 万なんですね
で 普通は人がたくさんの来るんだから
3 階でやってもらったけど
その日はもう私は 2 階で
それほど大きいホールでもなかったんですけど
で ちょっと休憩の時にそれをちょっと覗いて覗いてみたんですけど
この若者がまあもう２５ ６ ７ ８
歳でしょうね はい 悟りに達するためには
この呪文ですとかね もう伝授しているんです
金取って 呪文の言葉に意味がないことはありがたいんです
意味があったらね 調べられるでしょ？なんだらかんだらそうはあかとか
できれば本いっぱいありますからね
自分は昔みたい 昔はこれ秘密で
もう特別に弟子にイニシエーションしてしか教えなかったんですけど
今はもう商売になる 金になり金の文化になったんだから
まあ一応お金いくらかければ誰にでも教えてくれますし
本も出版して出します
それで入りますからね
だから本を開けてみてください
もう呪文というのは何千もあります
一行でも何の意味もないんです
それで信じますからね
明確な騙しでしょ はい
まあそんなところですね
宗教は またありますけどね
何万台と一回行ったら極楽道に行きますよと
極楽道はすごくいいところで
何もみじんも悪いことないでしょ
早く行けば それで仕事をしながら
奥さんと喧嘩しながら
もう言うこと聞かない子供と絡み合いながら苦労する必要ないでしょうに
命をかけて国民のために頑張りますね
政治家は しかし 国民はいつでもその今のまんまですね
国民のために命かけて
我々のことを心配で頑張ってますけど
我々の人生はそのまんまみじんもうまくいかないでしょうに
国民の意見をよく聞いて
それに従って政治をするでしょ
何か国民の意見をよく調べてから頑張りますと
えらい民主主義ですね
国民は皆 自分が投資しているような気分で喜んでいます
皆様もそうでしょう 私たちが自分たちで政治をやっている気分でしょ
皆様は 皆さんの意見を聞いている
あの連中は 選挙制度がなかったらね
その美しい言葉は聞けなくなりますよ
自分の首のために言ってるんです
首が飛んじゃいますから
選挙で まあまあ 政治家のことそこら辺にしてね
大企業もまあ結局は同じことなんですね
商売の世界は明らかに自分の利益で働きます
騙してないんです この大企業とかね
その人々は儲かるためにやってますから
そこら辺ははっきりしていますね
今年はこれぐらい利益上がりましたとかね
だからそこは騙してないんです
品物を作ったら これどれぐらい儲かるかなと考えていますね
だからはっきり言うことはいいことです
車を作っているのは あなた方に楽をさせたいよりは
うちは儲かりたいんだよと
どうしても楽をさせなきゃ買ってくれないんだから
まあいくらか色を変えたりとかね
何かしますよという程度なんですね
しかし 作る 開発する品物は世界一ですね
いつでも言うよねでしょ
これはもう我々は技術は世界一だと
でも買ってみたらそうじゃないね
何の欠陥もない 何の害もない
白物ばっかり 白物ばっかりなんです
言う時は何の欠陥もないと言うんだけど
買ってみたら白物で何の害もないと作っている食べ物やらいろいろね
あの放射線も体に何の害もないでしょ
まあ言ってますからね
消費者が買う気にならない場合は
時々消費者もね 騙されないぞと思って買わないことにします
その時は派手に宣伝しちゃえばね
派手に宣伝してマインドコントロールする
そうしてでも人を助けたいんですね
大企業は マインドコントロールして騙してでも我々のことを心配していますよ
信じてください また 科学
これまた騙し屋のプロなんです
科学にははちゃめちゃ騙されますよ
科学は事実を発見しますね
しかし 間もないうち 別な科学者がその事実を訂正するんです
だから騙しっぱなしでしょ
科学に騙されっぱなし
これこそ発見しました
これはこれやこれやとか言うでしょうね
でも後で違いますよと
あの科学者の研究ではなくて
新しい研究によって新しい事実が事実になりましたから
では信じましょうと だから明日科学者が何言うかわからないんですが
今日言っていることはその通り本当やと我々は今信じ込んでいますよ
だから科学者別に研究しますから
新しい事実を発見すると間違ったものを訂正しますよ
それはいいことですけど
具体的に我々生の人間が騙されっぱなしなんですね
薬開発の場合でも いい薬が
奇跡的な素晴らしい薬ができましたと言って飲ませるでしょ
あとでデータを取ったか取ったところで
あれは副作用ありすぎちゃって
人も死んだりして 本当にとんでもない悪いことやってても使用禁止にしますね
使用禁止になる 10 年間で我々は毒を飲ましていたんです
それで作った新しい薬も同じこっちゃでしょうに
だから騙されっぱなしなんです
彼らは必死で頑張っていることはわかりますけど
でも 薬会社とか今金だけ目当てにしているでしょ
薬産業はもう一番金儲かる
ものすごい商売なんですね
ですから  皆様のことをすごく心配しています
今事実を信じ込んでいる科学は
あと嘘でしたということになります
天文学的な数字のお金を使って宇宙開発
武器開発などしています
しているのは本当に人類のためなんです
300億ぐらい使ってロケットを作って打ち上げますけど
パーッと爆発しますね
瞬間全部消えますね あれで随分人類が助かっています
科学者の権力者のロマンのために
権力のためではありません
この科学研究は 科学者は自分のロマンのためにやっているわけじゃないんですよ
我々のためにやっています
信じましょう 正直な人の発見
親は子を騙す 子も負けないで親を騙す
友人同士でも利益が絡んだら裏切ってもそれほど悪くなさそうです
友人はあんまり騙さないんだけど
利益絡んじゃうとね その場合は黙ってもいいってことになってるんです
可愛い人を自分の所有物にするために
命よりもその人のことを愛してあげます
でしょ 命をかけても守る約束しますでしょ
信じてください 本当のことなので
女性の方々はこれを信じなくては罰が当たります
結局は人を騙せない人がいるということはありえない話です
そういうことで 世の中どこを見渡しても騙されているんです
騙っているんですよ だから騙せない
正直な人っていうのは存在もしないんです
触れたものを金にしてくれる賢者の石と似ています
話はありますね ある石
一個の石があって 何かに金属にタッチすると
その金属が金になります
ありがたいんです この石があればね
見つかりっこはないんで
だから正直な人っていうのは賢者の石と似ています
それは生命の自我の問題です
理由は私は怒って言っているわけじゃないんです
これは世の中の普通のことなんです
私にとっては冗談で何でもないんです
で やっぱり自我の問題なんですね
度を超えた騙しは断然罪ですが
だから度を超えて騙しちゃうと
これはもう断然罪なんです
完全に無くすためには
世の道ではなく ブッダの語られられた中道を実践することです
だからブッダの中道を歩まない限りは
この騙し問題は解決しません
これも騙しでしょうかと思うでしょう
じゃあ調べてください
どうですかと その自由があるんです
どんなやり方でもいいんだから
調べて調べて 研究して
批判して くったくったく
どんなことをやってもいいんです
騙されているのかと で
あの そこそこ我々は人を騙ってます
お母さんがね 子供を騙してますよ
まあそれは罪とは言いませんよ
まあまあまあ その程度のことでね
まあ子供もお母さんに嘘を言って
なんとかなんとか隠れてね
遊んだりもするし まあそれそこも罪だっていうことではなくて
度を超えちゃうとね 明らかに罪なんです
煩悩があるから騙される
死にたくはないとアホなことを考える
程度を超えた欲深い人
死にたくないと思ったら程度を超えています
このアホらしさは まるまるを信じたならば
死後永遠の天国だという話に乗ります
でしょ なんで世の中の人間が永遠の天国の話に簡単に乗っちゃいますね
相当度を超えたアホなんです
死にたくないというこの気持ちは
だからお釈迦様が朝晩念じなさいよと
あなたは死にますよと
必ず それ騙しじゃないでしょうに
守ってあげてるんです
しかし 死なないと天国に行けないのはオチです
永遠の天国はもう俺は永遠の天国
死ななきゃダメなんですね
死にたくないでしょ こいつは
だったら早く一緒に死んじゃえば？永遠の天国でしょうに
面白いことは 堂々と永遠の天国のことを喋る人々は一人も死なないんですね
ロールスロイス 車2 3台買うわ
もう飛行機は買うわ ものすごい商売は繁盛していますけど
それからもうものすごい警備なんですね
このテレエバンジェリストたちの家なんかはね
えらい警備で もう機関銃やらあっちこっちつけちゃったりして
もうね ネズミ一匹でも入るとレーザー光線ですぐそこを反応して
ギャーギャーともうもう警報なら鳴らうんですよ
そうと死にたくないでしょ
しかし その人はテレビで出て
永遠の天国を目の前に見せてくれるんです
手のひらで見せてくれるんです
だから ちょっと理性で見れば
もうそんな難しくないでしょ
騙されないでいることは
早く死ねと言えばそれで話終わりでしょうに
だから仏教ではね あるちっちゃな召使いの女の人が
とか別な話かな ちょっとダブってますけどね
あのブラマン人がこの牛を生贄にしてあげようと思ってね
準備しているんですね
ただ 仏教のグループは
あなたが友達何やってますか？と
うちの宗教ではね 神を喜ばせるために
この牛をね 生贄にしますと
だから今洗って花を飾って
もういろいろ もう何て言いますか
綺麗な あの汚れた餌を食べさせないで
で 今準備して もう 1 年間ももう準備させたんだと
この牛さんには はい これから生贄
生贄にしましょうと それでなんで神様の機嫌を取りますか？と聞いたら
そうすると神様は私たちを死後天国に連れてきますよと
そしたらこの死んでいく牛さんは
牛さんにはこれ以上ありがたいことはないでしょうにと
あのヒンドゥー インドの場合は人間にだけ魂あるとは言わないんです
ですっごい汚い性格悪い連中が
魂は人間だけやと言うんです
もともと魂はないんだけど
インド教ではそうじゃなくて
生命はみんなに魂があるんだよと言うんですね
ですから この牛さんにとってはね
神のために命差し上げる
そんな偉い こんなすごいことないでしょうにと
だから牛さんが先に天国に行きますよと
そしたらこの仏教のグループは
だったらおじさんたちが自分で死んじゃったらもっと早く行けるでしょうにと
かわいそうで 牛さんより後で行くの
情けないでしょうにと
という単純な答えなんです
だって宗教家であるブラマン人である聖典を暗記している人が
ずいぶん後で天国に行きますけど
何もしない牛さんがさっと先に行ってますからね
だから嘘であること 騙していること
ただ牛を殺して食いたいだけなんです
だから神に祝福された肉だからありがたくいただくんです
それで病気治りますよとかね
商売繁盛しますよとか言って
ただ単に肉食いたいだけなんです
本当のところは それで最悪感にも悩ませてほしくないんです
だって牛に魂があると言ってるんだから
だから自分も黙ってるんです
そういうわけで この世の中の騙しっていうのは本当にシンプルで解けます
私はこの話は今教えているんです
ちょっと厳しいかもしれませんだけど
私の言葉は しかし そう言わなきゃ目が覚めないでしょ
永遠の天国を信じる人は
なぜ一斉に自殺することを考えないんですかね
例えば あなたに 1,000万あげますよと 40年経ってからと言ったらね
あまり面白くないはないでしょうに
40年も生きているかもわからないし
生きていたにしたっても
自分が 80歳だからね 1
億はどうでもいいでしょうに
くれれば今くれと だからこの上のない究極な幸福である
永遠な天国がね 今すぐ入った方が理性的でしょ
だからそうならないことはね
嘘を言っていることなんです
人を騙すんだけど 自分は騙されませんという態度なんです
子供が病気になったら
親が神に頼む それも煩悩でしょ
子供が病気になると お母さんがもういても立ってもいられなくなっちゃいますね
子供をすごくもう愛情があるんだからね
そこでどんな神社でも
どんなところでも行って
どんなことでもやります
で 子供が治してくれるならばというね
だからその場合も騙されてますけど
病気だったら病院に行くしかないんだけど
騙されてますね なんでお母さん騙されるかというと
やっぱり子供を愛するという煩悩があるんだからなんです
だからそこは別に文句言ったっても意味がないんですね
我が子を愛するのはね
まあ普通なことだから
しかし 度を越えてますね
この宗教の世界では 死にたくはないとかね
もう病気ですね それで大量に騙されてますよ
世の中の人間は だから騙されるのは煩悩があるからなんです
金が欲しい 権力が欲しい
性欲を満たしたい 結婚したい
将来は不安だなどの束縛があれば
必ず誰かにカモになります
まあ商売繁盛するでしょ
南無妙法蓮華経ってなんとかとなれば
病気も治ります やる人いますよ
たくさん 日本で しかし
病院は減ってないんです
日本人口の半分以上やってますけど
だから 例えば結婚したい
結婚したいと思うんだけど
なかなか相手が見つからないと
縁結びの神社に行くでしょうね
なんでって やっぱり煩悩があるんだからなんです
この性欲を満たした人々は開祖様になるんです
あの麻原さんも自分の弟子たちには性欲禁止しちゃったんです
みんなもう若者ばっかりでしたでしょ
みんなに友達がいたんです
だから全部自分もらったんです
あんた方はもうすぐ別れなさいと
しかし 二人で浸透しなさいと
女たちは別グループで
麻原さんの所有物なんですね
あの女優さんも同じことやっちゃって
今も彼が派手に宗教を広げてますけど
自分のすごい美人の女の人と友達になっていたんですけど
麻原さんはいただきました
それで麻原さんは最終解脱だから
成功することが やられる人にとってはもう最大の幸福だそうです
信じていましたからね
彼が犯罪を起こさなかったならば
いまだに信じているでしょう
150の煩悩があるから
間違った 1510の煩悩があるから
まあこの数字はちょっとおしゃれに
まあほんと数えてますけど
覚えなくてもいいんです
それぐらい騙される引っ掛けを持っていると思った方が良いんです
気をつけてください 我々は1510ぐらいの引っ掛けは持ってます
それで引かれます 引っかかります
ですから 煩悩を制御する生き方は
騙されないために安全装置になります
だから怒らないで 欲張らないで
無知にならないで生きるとかなり
だから私は微妙な理性で
今の世の中にある嘘は全部一発でバラしちゃったでしょ
何のこともなく ギャーギャーギャー理論することもなく
すごい時間かかったのは
ブッダの理論説明するためなんです
世間のことは一言で悪い
はでは信じますではっちゃいます
そういうことで 煩悩を制御すると騙されないようになります
はい 次のテーマ 疑心暗鬼
ここまでの話は疑心暗鬼を応援したことになります
だって誰も信じられないんだからね
しかし 違います 疑心暗鬼になるのは
信じているのに なんとか何とかという無知な人なんです
あの人のことを信じていたのにこうされましたという人が疑心暗鬼になるんです
疑心暗鬼になります 自分が悪いんです
なんで信じたんですかね
恋人同士でもね 恋人は徹底的に信じていたのにとかね
裏切れたと振られたところで
ガクンと落ち込んじゃうでしょ
時々立ち直れなくなる場合もあるでしょ
自分が悪いんです それで疑心暗鬼に陥ったっても
人間不信になっちゃっても自分が悪いんです
なんで信じたんですかと
初めから 初めからもうそこそこ
それはもう牛安亭でお互い様
もうご利益ある時だけ成り立つものやと覚えておけばよかったのに
疑心暗鬼は ん？これ道じゃないんです
無知の証拠です 悟りに達していない生命は初めから信頼に値しないんです
生命は悟りに達していないならば
誰も信じることはできないんです
信じちゃうと自信疑心暗鬼になるんです
だから初めからもう まあ冬は寒いんだよと
夏は暑いんだよという程度で当たり前やと
そんな驚くことはないという冷静でいればどうですかね
自分に自分のことも信頼できないんです
私たちにも自信がないんです
これからどうしようかとかね
これから悪いことを絶対しないだろうと
そんな自信ないでしょうに
そういうことですから
自分のことさえも悟ってないんだから信頼できないんですよ
だからもう人のことを信頼するとあまりにも無知でしょうに
だからそこで疑心暗鬼をなくしてください
私のこともちょっと自分には信頼できませんよと
だから世の中のことをなぜ信頼するの？まあまあ
それ普通だから まあほどほどにしましょうよ
誰だけでしょうね 自分のことさえも信頼できない身分なのだと思って落ち着いてしまいましょう
人の話に乗るか乗らないかを自分で判断しましょう
だから私のことも信頼できないし
相手のことも信頼できないし
ではこの話に乗るかなと
乗れないかなとか乗らないかな
自分で決めればいいでしょ
はい 乗り回すと決めたら自分の責任で別にどうってことないでしょうに
乗って騙されたと発見したならば
私が決めたことだから
相手を恨むことは損害だと思うことでしょうね
私が自分で決めて買っちゃったんだからね
まあしょうがない まあまんまと騙されたんですよ
まあしょうがない 恨む必要ないやと決めるしかないんです
私も試してみました この薬は効きます
ということは限り出ますから
私の言葉じゃないんです
人はそう言うんです 神の手を持っている医者がいます
紹介してあげます その場合は神の手っていうのは神じゃなくて
すごい腕がいいという言葉です
納豆を食べるとがんは治りますとテレビで言われました
それっきり私は納豆を食べることは極力控えました
はい どういたしますかね
こんなこと言われると
この薬はね もうあなたも同じ病気でしょ
私はこれ飲んでみたんですけど
本当にすごく見事に治りましたと
ある人が私にも何か薬草とか送ってあったんですけど
自分の子供たちのアレルギーとかなんとかって
これは見事に治りましたと
だから私はなんで飲むんですかね
アレルギーはないんだけど
ただ体が弱くてもう食べてもあまり消化しないだけなんです
だからその人は私を騙そうとしているんですかね
こういう風な言葉を言っている人は
我々を騙そうとしていますかね
そこが問題なんです 本当は正直なんです
騙す気持ちはないんです
しかし 騙されますけどね
この人々は戦地洗脳ではありません
この科学的に調べてないんです
ただ自分の気持ちを言ってるだけなんです
信じ込んでいるんです
ただ 理性がなくかもしれませんを言葉に加えないという間違いを犯している
許してあげてください
だから彼らはかもしれませんというこれつけないんですよ
私はこの薬では結構楽になってましたけど
あなたも同じ病気だから治るかもしれませんと
このかもしれません 必要なんです
それ言わないんです そこでお釈迦様がこのかもしれませんということはとても大事にしているんです
真理を知らない人々にも真理を守ることできますよと
悟らなくても真理は守ることはできますよと
それどういうことかというと
私は神がいると信じていますと
言えば お前バカやということを言えないんですね
私はあの人言っていることが正しいと
正しいと言ったらダメなんです
あの人言ってることは正しい
ダメ 絶対言ってはいけません
あの人言っていることは正しいと思います
その一言が必要なんです
思いますというのは私一人ですから
あなたもそう思いなさいはないでしょ
黙ってないんです ですから
真理を守っている あの人言っていることは
もしかすると嘘だとしましょう
自分が別に賛成意見出してないんだから
私は正しいと思いますと
それだけなんですね だから私はこうだと思います
私はこうだと信じています
いうふうに このもうちょこっとこのコンディショナルことを入れてください
言葉に 喋る時でも毎日
それで頭が良くなります
これはもう私の気持ちですとかね
あの人は私はあの人は嫌い
大嫌いって言ってはいけません
私の気持ちはなんか嫌いっていう気持ちですよと
ですから その人はいい人であっても悪い人であっても
それは構わないでしょ
そうじゃなくて いきなり戦地洗脳の気分でぶん殴るでしょ
あいつは悪い人やとかね
そう言っちゃうと もうとんでもない人間なんです
私は悪いと思いますけど
というコンディショナル条件をつけた方が真理を守る人間になりますよと
それやりやすいでしょ
しかし 頭が良くないとできないんです
それが 言っちゃいますね
断言的な言葉は 騙せないようにする技
相手のことを慈しみます
だから世界は私を騙そうしてるでしょ？私は世界を恨まなくなる
恨まないことにする みんなそういうことだから
生命はみんな大変だよと
みんな自害でむちゃくちゃなことをやってるんだとかね
いうことに気持ちになります
慈しみを抱きます 人のことを真面目に心配する気持ちになります
向こうは騙そうとして喋るかもしれませんだけど
それでも心配するんです
で 私のところに昔 いろいろ時々人が来ます
日本ではないことではないんだけど
来て まあいろんなストーリーを言うんですね
自分がもう大変でもうなんとか仕事をしていたんですけど
あんまりよく給料はなかったんですけど
まあトレーで怪我して足が折って仕事をできなくなりましたと言っても
歩く時でもなんかすごいなんか変な歩き方で
もう歩けないんだと で
それで子供がもう 4人もいますけどね
もう一番上のはもう身体障害者で
2番目はなんだか病気で
3番目には目が見えなくてとかね
奥さんがもう倒れちゃって動かないんだとかね
わかるでしょ？金いくらかくれって話でしょ
で 言ってるストーリーは作り話だから
私に矛盾がダラダラダラダラ見えているんです
例えば骨が折って歩く
ありえないでしょ 骨が折れたら歩けないっていうことは
骨はすぐ治りますからね
そこでお金がないんだから治療できなかったっていうことは
自分の国ではありえないんです
自分の国では無料で治療してあげます
金ある人はもう金払って
もう立派な ただ建物だけ立派な病院に行くんです
医者は同じです 一般政府の病院で仕事をして
ちょっと政府許可もらって
8時間も仕事をしないで
もう 6時間ぐらい仕事をして逃げるんです
逃げて金持ちの病院で仕事するんです
いて 金またがっぷりもらっちゃうんです
同じ医者なんです だから大丈夫です
だから医者ってのは専門家だから
この貧乏な人だから足を曲げてつなぎましょうと
ありえないでしょうに
医者になった瞬間で 医者の役柄になった瞬間で
相手に金があるかないか
まるっきり頭に入らないんです
この病気しか見えないんです
あの人々には ですから大丈夫
だからあんなのはもう嘘ももう決まってますけどね
しかし私は心配するんですね
ここまで変な歩き方をしながら
変なもう体はすごい不自由だとね
演技しながら さすが苦しいでしょうにと
この人にとっては とにかく仕事をしないで
人の金パクって楽に生活したいという企みでしょうにと
はい それでも楽じゃないよと
あなたにはと どこかに仕事をした方がもっと楽やと
立場もありますよと 普通の労働者として仕事をしてもね
まあかっこいいんですよ
自分で仕事をしてるんだっていうことはね
だから人を騙そうとしたっても
自分がね ここまでやってますからかわいそうやなと私は思うんですね
思って はい よくわかりましたと言って
まあ結構お金あげます
だから本人が期待するお金よりあげます
とにかく 本人はまあもうお寺だから
もう普通はもうまあ50ルピーですからって 50
ルピーぐらいはそう考えてますけど
私は250ルピーとかね 300
ルピーとかあげるんです
そこで本人が何のことを
本人が見事に騙された
この坊主はと思っちゃうんです
思った瞬間で それでお坊さんもう子供にはね
ミルクをあげなくちゃいけないんだから
粉ミルク一つ二つくれませんかと
あ そう それからと あと石鹸があればとかね
タオルあれ だいたいお寺にあるものですね
それからリスト来る それで私はお前帰りなさいと
その時言うんです いい加減帰りなさいと
人を騙すのはきりがありますよ
だからそこははっきり教えてあげます
騙されたと思ってるんですね
騙されてないんです ただ
人が貧乏であることは確かな事実ですから
あそこまで惨めで苦労しているんだから
仕事した方が楽なのに
バカもありありでしょうね
だから助けるべきでしょうね
だから助けるべきだから助けたんだって
騙されたわけじゃないんです
騙されたと乗って話するときは
ものすごい厳しいことを言うんです
ある女の人にそうやって大量に品物をどっかにあげたところで
またさらに子供が 3人いるんだから
もうもうあれやこれや始めたんです
いけない あのね お前帰ると子供は私が作ってないでしょうにと
お前作ったんだからてめえ面倒見りゃいいと
そしたらすごく坊さんのくせになんて汚いこと言うのかと
もう二度と喋らないことにします
で そこ例に出したのは
やっぱり相手のことを心配すると騙されたことにならないんです
たとえお金あげても 自分があげてるだけ取られたじゃないんです
だから取られる前にあげてください
その方が騙されてないんです
ですから この人のことを真面目に心配する
そうすると騙されなくなります
自分の利益より相手の利益を先に考えます
で もう結構 例えば話すと
向こうも利益考えていて
自分も利益あるんだから
品物を買ったりするでしょうね
だからあなたはまあどうですかね
どれぐらいどの人はこんなことを売ったら儲かるかなとかね
という相手の利益を先に考えると
騙されなくなります 自分の利益で話しているならば
正直にその旨を相手に言ってお願いしますとします
例えば 自分が本当にもう金取りたいんですね
自分の利益しか考えていないんですね
例えば 親から金をおねだりするときは
親のことはまるっきり心配しないでしょ
金だけくれと そこであれやこれやとかね
言って親を騙そうとしない方がいいんです
単純に自分の利益で話を
例えばどこか商売の相談に行く
ただ 買う人がもうどうなってもいいんだけど
自分がこれぐらいの商売しておかないと
自分の立場が悪いんだよね
会社で だから自分の利益のために必死になってもう押し売りしているんですね
その時一回正直に言ってみてください
お願いします なんとか 1個だけでも買ってくれれば私が助かりますよと
私にはこういうふうに言われてね
もうものすごい苦しいんだと
自分の気持ち 自分が自分の利益だけ考えているんだよと正直に言っちゃうとうまくいくんです
いえいえ 奥様 これは奥様買ったら得しますよと言っちゃうとうまくいかないんです
そういうわけで 騙されないために
自分が本当に自分の利益ばっかり考えていても構いませんよ
しょうがないんだから
人間だからね その時正直に言っちゃいなさいと
例えば嫌がってる人ともうもう付き合って結婚したがりますよ
向こうは逃げようとすると
いえ もうあなたにはいろんないい人が見つかるかもしれませんだけど
私はあなたと一緒にいた方がすごく幸せですよと
私がものすごく助かりますと言っちゃうと
自分の方を見てくれます
結婚もしてくれます そんなに難しくないんです
やり方さえ知っていけば
自分が信頼できる人間になっていく過程で
他人に自分を騙すことはできなくなります
それが法則です 理論です
自分が信頼できる人間になればなるほど
相手が騙すことがどんどん減らちゃうんです
私が個人的に仲良くしているグループは
もう日本ではあまりないんだけど
自分の国ではいるんだけど
みんな信頼関係を作っているんですね
そのどんないろんな人がいますよ
もう知識人からもうまるっきり知識もない
だらしない性格悪い人まで知っている人はいますけど
みんな私のことは完全完璧に信頼するんですね
だから人を騙す人でも私を騙すことはしないんです
その時に笑って何か欲しいからなんかちょうだいねとかね
なんでやと なんでしたって欲しいんだからとか
それだけ これだからこれだから
これだからね これこれっとないんです
親しくしている人々は
何のことなく これこれこれと言うだけです
私はあげませんとか 持ってけとどっちかなんです
それであるいはお前にあげるもんかいと言われてあげるもんかいと言ったっても持っていけます
持っていっても騙されたと思わないし
向こうも私を騙したと思わないんですね
むちゃくちゃ信頼しているんだからっていうことなんです
そういうことで 信頼をね
自分で作っていけば あのすごい性格悪い小さな昔々話です
まあ大人ここがいて ものすごい性格悪いんですね
誰の話も聞かないんです
で 育てられない こいつはもう犯罪者になるかもしれません
で 怖い 怖いぐらいですね
私はこの子を育ててみせるとと思ったんです
だからといって もうほんのちょっちょっとな付き合いなんですけど
まずその子にね 誰もその子を相手にしないんだから
こそこそと内緒で私と友達になってくれませんかと聞いたんです
そしたらびっくりしちゃって
いいよと言うんですね
それで友達なんですね
友達は裏切れませんでしょ
私は真面目にその子をすごく可愛がってあげて
その子をやっている あれこれやって何も何も言いません
それで本当にもうみるみるうちに
2  3週間でみんなに愛される立派な子になっちゃったんです
みんな忘れちゃった 今まですっごい極限に悪ガキでしたっていうことは
いつでもいい子やったから
これもう助かりますよとかね
だからこのすごい簡単ですよ
で これが詐欺ではうまくいかないので
私も正直であの子はもう友達にしますと
年はむちゃくちゃ年の差があるんだけど
当時私は大学で教えてて
こいつはもう小学生でしたしね
友達になる気はないでしょうに
でもそこら辺では正直で
そこで私の友達だから
この子は私に適した人間にならなくちゃいけないでしょ
何の苦労もなくそうなっていくんですね
勉強もするし 頭も良くなっちゃうし
もういろいろ勉強しろという必要もないし
だから一生懸命私と対等になってやろうと頑張っているんです
これすごいいいことでしょうに
歳では対等になりませんだけど
知識で能力で もうとにかくいつかあなたを負かしてみせますよと私に挑戦までするんですね
はいはい 頑張ってくださいと
そういうことで信頼を買っちゃえば
もうものすごい楽々なんです
これで続けていますかね
もう時間になりましたけど
はい それで一応今日の話はここら辺で終了ですけど
まあまあちょっと今日時間余ると思っていたんですから
もうちょっと入れたんです
付録として 仏教からブッダが説く信仰から身を守る技
カーラマ族の町に町を釈尊が訪ねます
宗教家が自説のみ正しく
他説はすべて偽物だというから
皆の話を総合すると偽物になりますと
なります 私たちは宗教の話に疑問を抱いています
と宗教を信仰する気持ちはないことを釈尊に告げます
カーラマという町に行ったんだけど
カーラマ族という人々が住んでいたんですけど
このものすごい知識人なんですね
みんな だから宗教家が狙い狙っていくんですね
頭のいい人が自分の宗教を浸透すると
もう結構商売は繁盛します
だから一つの宗教が言って
自分の教えこそ正しくて
あの人の教え あの人のあれは断然間違ってますよと言うんですね
ただ 別の宗教家も言って
この教えだけ正しくて
俺はダメダメダメダメと言っちゃうんですね
それでカーラムさんたちは知識人でしょ
全部総合してみるんですね
例えば宗教は 30ぐらいあるとしましょう
一人の宗教家が自分の教えが正しいと賛成券を入れる
で  39の数字何でしたっけ？前は 30でしたっけね
はい  29の宗教が間違いと投票するでしょ
そこで次の宗教家が来て
ある宗教 自分の宗教の箱に投票 1票入れて
他の宗教はダメ ダメ ダメ
ダメと投票するでしょ
それで 30人も投票して終わってから
じゃあ計算してみます
どうなりますかと 賛成券 1個で
否定券は 29 次の箱を開けてみてたら
賛成券は 1個で 否定券は 29
次の箱を開けてみても
賛成券は 1票で 否定券は 29票
どうなりますか？それでカーラムさんではすべてが間違っていると
宗教家が信頼できませんと言って無神論者になっちゃったんです
だからお釈迦様には最初にそれを報告してた
無駄をするなよと あなたも
しかし お釈迦様は釈尊
理性のある君たちの態度は正しいと褒めました
さすが正しいですね あなた方は
と 理性を保つ方法を教えたんです
ですから しっかりと理性で生きてましょう
生きましょうと言って
理性について語っちゃったんです
カーラムさんたちの能力について
誰は間違っている 私は正しいという話じゃないんです
理性に基づいて自分が決めるという
1 マアヌッサヴェーナ
いい伝えだから いわゆる聖典とかありますね
いい伝え  2000年  3000年もいい伝えでしょうとか
ヴェーダ聖典というのは 3000年よりも古いので
紀元前 3000年です
出来上がったのは しかし
中身は全くむちゃくちゃ
もういい加減だらしない嘘なんです
みんなすごい信仰している
コーランという本があるでしょ
あんなの頭がイカれている以外は誰も読みません
それぐらい中身はむちゃくちゃなんです
で なんで読みますかというと
あれは歌う本なんですね
だからきれいなメロディーを歌えるんです
だからその作った人々が節を美しく歌えることしか考えていない
だから言葉はむちゃくちゃつなげてるだけ
我々 今最近歌っている歌と同じなんです
何か単語を入れちゃえばいいっていうことで
そういうわけで このいい伝えだからといって信じるなかれと
2番目 マーパランパラよ
伝統だから 伝統的に我々はこういうことを信仰していますよと
これはうちの伝統だといって信じるなよ
そんなのは と マーイティキラヤ
みんなこれを言ってるからとかね
例えばマスコミとかね
テレビ放送とかね 新聞とかだらだらだらだら言ってるんだけど
真実だからって真実かどうかわからないでしょうに
それで決めるなよと まあピタカサンパダーでテキストにありますからと言って
古いテキストを持ってきて
ほら こっちにありますよと
だから何と いわゆる真理であるという証拠になりません
例えば どこかの本に誰かが書いたならば
なんとかなんとか 天皇が朝回と昼回と午後回はもう神様に祈りながら飛び上がりましたよと
テキストにあるんだからって
そのそのなんだらかんだら天皇が必ずそうやったってことにならないでしょ
まあなぜへとまるまる理論に合っている
何か抜けちゃったね  5番目
まあタッカへと理屈に合う
すごい理屈 まあすごい論ですね
だから事実ではないんです
まあないヘッドっていうのは
この子の理論から見れば
まあこれが合ってますとかね
だから何やと まあ例えば
先知 先知 先農の神がいるという理論に基づいて考えると
ジーザスが受難したことが合ってますね
だから事実事実にならんでしょうね
まあアーカーパリヴィタッキーな話し方を見ると一貫性がある
誰でも 特に放送局のアナウンサーたちがね
喋るとか すごい見事に喋るでしょ
すごい一貫性があって
明確にわかるように喋るんですね
だからと嘘でも言えますよ
そういうふうに プロのアナウンサーだから
喋り屋さんだから そういうことは一つも真理の証拠にならないんです
またあります まあディッキニージャナカントリー
自分の考えに 信仰に合っているから
あ うちも同じ考えですよとか言って飛ぶなよと
あんた間違ってるかもしれませんし
その人間違ってるかもしれませんし
あ 私もそういう気持ちでしたよとかね
きゅう まあバッバルーパだよ
それもあり得る話だから
我々やられちゃいます
それで あ そういえばあり得る
あり得る そんなことはと
あり得るだけであって
あったわけじゃないでしょうに
10番目 まあさまののがる
釈尊のことを尊敬しているから信じるなよと
10番目 お釈迦様 自分を入れちゃいます
なぜかというと このカーラム族はなんでお釈迦様に先にあなた無理するなよと言ったんですかというと
釈尊のことは尊敬しているんです
釈尊はだらしない宗教家とはちょっと違いますが
でもあなたも宗教でしょ
信じませんよという態度なんです
だからお釈迦様は 私のことをあなた方は信仰
信仰じゃなくて尊敬しているんだからといって話に乗るなよと
で 我々の世界でお釈迦様はいないんだけど
我々はあの人は偉い 東大を卒業している
あのブッダの生まれ変わりのやつも東大卒業ですからね
そういうことに乗るなよと
むちゃくちゃインチキ言って人を騙すんだからね
そういう人で その肩書きを人を騙すために使っているでしょうに
だから博士号をいくつか持っている人でも
その人に限って騙せますよ
簡単に だから その 10項目に気をつけてください
その 10項目も真理であることには証拠にならないんだよと
お釈迦様は言うのは理性に基づいて自分で判断してくださいと
これは善であり これは悪でありと自分自身で知ってから
これパーリ語ではアッタナーヴァージャーネイアと
やっぱりこれが悪いことですねと
自分でわかったらやめましょうよと
やっぱりブッダがダメと言ったんだからやめますとはちょっとかっこ悪いんです
例えば ブッダが嘘をつくなと言ったんだから
私は嘘をつきませんよというとかっこ悪いんです
弱いんです ではなくて
ブッダがおっしゃろうがなかろうが
関係なく 嘘は悪いことだからやめてますよと言ったら強いんですね
これは善でありと これは悪でありと
自分自身で知ってから善を行いなさい
悪をやめなさいと説かれたんです
それからお釈迦様はもう議論で
では君たちに聞きます
欲はいいことですか？いい
お釈迦さん 欲は悪いでしょうに
では 欲で人が喋ったり考えたり行動したりする
その行為はいいと思う？いい
それは悪い行為だよと
でしたら その行為をやめることでしょ
はい その通りですと その行為をやるんですか？やめるんで
やめますよと言ったら
ほら見てよと 今あなた方は判断したでしょうにと
私が言ってないでしょうにと
お釈迦様はもうしつこく言うんですね
ほら カーラミよ あなた方は伝統にも乗らないで
言い伝えにも乗らないで
聖書にも乗らないで テキストも乗らないで
私は偉いんだからといって
私の話にも乗らないで
自分たちで決めたでしょうにと
その通りやと それから怒りについて
無知について同じことをされていくのです
たとえ知識人であっても騙されます
それよく気をつけてください
ここで知識人の弱みを説明してあります
このカーラマーさんたちが知識人なんですね
しかし 弱みがある 知識人がいろんなことを参考にするんですね
テキスト 人のお話 あれやこれやとか
知らないうちに乗ってしまいます
だから知識人にも知識人の弱みがあるんです
それで宗教信仰から騙されることなく身を守ることができます
だからお釈迦様はこの10項目でね
宗教から身を守る方法で教えましたけど
それで世界の騙しことからも
我々に身を守ることはできます 10
項目を覚えておけば はい
まあこんなところで講演を終了すると思います
まだあります 完全に騙されない
いわゆる騙されない 騙せない人
完全に煩悩をなくした人です
騙されない 騙さないということは
煩悩が一切なしなんです
その人は 自分の利益に完全に達したので
利益を求める必要はないんです
悟ったんだからね 自分の利益は完璧にもう完成しています
もういらん 覚者に生命に対して憐れみしかないので
信じることに値する 悟った人にはもう何も慈悲も何もないんです
しかし 人々はまだ大変だなという
みんな苦しんでいるんだという憐れみはありますね
だから断言 信頼できるのはそういう悟った人
ブッダですね 他をいかなる理由でも騙すことはしないんです
どんな理由があっても
ブッダは人を騙しません
現象の世界に対する真理を発見しているから
語っている言葉は事実のみです
そこで悟るということは
すべて知り尽くすことでもありますね
だから 科学者よりもブッダが言うことは真実なんです
科学者の話は嘘じゃないんだけど
訂正しなくちゃいけないんですね
ブッダの言葉は訂正なしなんです
そのまんまです 変わらない
理由は真理を発見しているんです
だからブッダが語る言葉はそのまま真理なんです
はい 終わりです では どうもありがとうございます
えっと 予定の時間は過ぎておりますが
もし質問などある方でしたら
少し短い時間になりますけど
受け付けたいと思いますが
どなたかございますでしょうか
あ ちょっと今マイク持ってきます
ちょっと待ってください
ありがとうございます
質問一つなんですが 原発事故の処理の犠牲になる人は現実的に
自己犠牲なんですけども
道徳 道徳になるというふうに伺ったと思うんですけども
やっぱり戦争で犠牲になりたいと思って特攻隊みたいになる人たちと同じように思えて
私はちょっと納得がいかなかったんですが
その辺はちょっともう少し詳しく教えていただければと思います
簡単で戦争ではそうなりません
これは非道徳です 戦争はいかなる理由があっても非道徳なんですね
仏教は認めません 戦争は
この場合は人殺しに行っていくわけじゃないんだからね
この場合は確実に人を助けているんです
我々には本当に具体的に安心をしてあげようと思っているんだからね
戦争とは違いますね 戦争はもう本当に人を殺すことですよ
人の幸福を壊すことなんです
それはもう悪なんです
世の中で戦争は正当化していますが
仏教は全くもそれは正当化
正しいと思わないんです
そこら辺はあまりはっきりしてください
皆さんは何信仰していてもいいんだけど
仏教の立場では戦争は断然悪
しかし こういう本当に具体的な人を助けることは
はっきりと白いですね
戦争の場合でも 例えば恐ろしいもう
もう何て言いますか 独裁者がいて
国民は殺すは殺すは殺すは
それで暴動が起きて 独裁者を捕まって
その軍隊も潰して平和な国を作ったとしましょう
はい その場合は灰色なんですね
その場合は これは戦後
それでもならないんです
その場合 どういうことかというと
100人を殺しちゃって
1000万人を助けたことなんですね
しかし  100人殺した罪は 100人殺した罪で
1000万人助けた罪は徳は 1000万を助けた罪で
それぞれは別々になるんです
チャラになるわけじゃないんです
重さはどちらかといえば
そこは重さを量ってみることできますけど
善の方が重いと言っても
罪の方もありますということなんです
原発の場合は罪はゼロなんですね
それだけ  他にお願いします
はい 今マイク  先生  マイク
よろしくお願いします
先生が 3月18日に調布で被災された方に対しての心構えというものを出されましたよね
その時に 自分の命を次のして苦しみの人を救えというふうに書かれているんですけども
自分の命を次のして そこのところを若い人はちょっと先ほどおっしゃったようなおっしゃいましたけども
私たちは第二次世界大戦の前は特攻隊のように自分の命を犠牲にして戦えというふうに言われたように
ちょっと聞こえてしまうんですよね
だからそこをそれはある意味で仏教に縛られるというふうな形で
日本人はなんか思うような気がするんですね
私には でも 先生の今日の講義で私はわかりましたけども
若い人たちはそこをちょっと怖がっているっていうところもあるので
ちょっと教えてください
勝手に妄想して文章を読んでくると困りますけど
我々被災の時に限って言っていることで
その時は自分の命を次の素にして人のことを心配するということは
なんて美しい素晴らしいことでしょうね
それで自分にも力が出てくるしね
お互い助かるし 助け上げなくちゃいけない時でしょうに
こんなところで言っていいのかどうか分かりませんだけど
特攻隊の連中は何人を助けたんですかね
日本人があるんです  だから自分たちの頭が悪いということは
私の責任じゃないでしょうに
特攻隊が自分が犠牲になったことで
命何個助かりましたと
私は具体的に聞いているんです
助かった どこかに国に行って
自分がそのまま自害することで人死んだだけでしょうね
例えばパールハーバーに行ってもう死んじゃったことで
日本人何人助かったんですかね
自分の命を二の次にやるのは人を助けるためでしょ
だから一人を救いました
二人救ったと ちゃんと計算があるでしょうに
だから戦争は断然ダメなんです
ただ行って殺すだけなんです
しかし テロリストが 40人の子供たちとか人々を捕まえて
もう殺してやるぞとかね
我々の条件をちゃんと聞いてくださいとかね
その時はまあ正しいやり方はテロリストと話し合って
まあなんとかしてもう人々を救済することなんですけど
もうそんなそれほどみんなに撃ち続けるがないんだから
もう軍隊の特攻隊みたいなね
まああのスペシャルタスクフォースというね
すごい厳しい訓練を受けてる人々いるでしょ
その人々はもう裏から
後ろから 屋根から いろんなところから囲まって
テロリストはもう何人いるかと
まあ 5人いるんだと 武器はこれこれぐらいだと思って
なんのことか狙い撃ちで 5人も殺す
で 殺してからさっさとみんなを 40人の人々を救ってあげる
その場合ははっきりと 5人殺しました
40人を助かりましたと数字的に成り立ってるでしょうに
その場合は 5人を殺したことは罪であって
40人の命を助けたことは素晴らしい善であります
そういうふうにはっきりと答えがないと
いい加減はダメなんです
感情はダメなんです 信仰はダメなんです
この特攻隊は仏教が作ったじゃないでしょうに
これは神道でしょ 天皇が神やと思ったんだから
宗教  何を  宗教がやっぱり私たちを縛ったんですよね
宗教で言ったって仏教じゃないでしょうに
でも仏教は根に日本人はあると思うんですよね
それも勘違いでしょう
神道で言ったでしょうに
私は今日わかりましたけども
若い子供は結局この自分の命を二の次にしてというのがわからないっていうふうに
それわかってほしいんです
今日わかりました 私はわかりました
自分の命を二の次にして人を助けるんです
しかし しっかりと助かってほしい
ただ馬鹿やってる意味がないんです
昔 ニュースでありましたよ
あるおじいさんがこの
で 孫と一緒に孫が遊びに来てね
で 孫を喜ばせてあげようと思ってね
ボートに乗って川に行ったんですよ
そこで孫がもうどうせ孫はもうあれやこれやじゃれますから
これでボートで落ちちゃったんですね
川に 落ちた瞬間で もうおじさんがガクンと川に飛び込んだんです
孫 を助けてあげようと
いいことですけど 二人は死んじゃったんです
だからそこをどう評価するのかと
だから命かけて助けてほしいんだけど
助けてほしいんです それでなんとかしておじいさんが自分が死んでもいいんだから
孫を助けてあげましたと言ったら
いくらかプラスになります
なぜかというと おじいさんの先を考えたら
あとであと十年かもしれませんし
この子はもっとずっと人生延びますから
じゃあおじいさんの十年がなくなっちゃって
まあ子供は六十年過ぎ生きますから
それで亡くなったね 十年引いてみると五十年は得していますね
損得で考えれば まあいい加減な計算ですけど
一応あ よかったという結論には達しますね
しかし それでも孫から見れば
おじいさんが自分のために命を捨てたんだからね
これ結構精神的な負担にはなります
やっぱりあの損は結構効きます
もしおじいさんがむちゃくちゃ苦労して孫も助けておじいさんも助かったならば
うちのおじいさんが強いやと一生ありがたく思っちゃうんですね
こんなことまでやっちゃったと
それで川に溺れて病気になって
肺炎にもなっちゃって
私はもう何のこともなかったんですけど
おじいさんは 1ヶ月間も病院にいましたよとかね
言っても そこを考えるともうありがたくてたまらないでしょ
だから だから理論的には自分犠牲になることはダメです
間違いなんです しかし
ケースバイケースで犠牲になることは避けられない時もありますね
原発の処理に行っちゃうと
被爆することがもうどうしても避けられない
しかし 被爆はしたくない
その人々も 被爆はしたくない
自分にも家族がいる したくないんだけど
これ避けられないんですね
だから自己犠牲は避けられない時だけ成り立つものなんです
はい そういうところで
この変なね 宗教観で 仏教でない宗教観で
この間違ったらまあ私は知ったことではありませんね
すいません だいぶ時間が過ぎておりますので
これで終了させていただきたいと思います
それでは最後に回向の文を読ませていただきます
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒をあとに お釈迦様とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られた功徳と
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますよう
そして解脱が得られますよう
サッビーティヨー ヴィヴァッジャンツー サッブローブー ヴィナッサトゥー マテー バワントラー ヨー スティーディー
ガー ユコー バヴァ バワトゥ サッブ マングラントゥ サッブ デバタ サッブ ムンターヌバーヴェーナ サッブ
ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サッブ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダ スッティー バワントゥティー アビワーダナ シーリスー
ニッチャンワッダー パチャノー チャッター ルーダンマー ワッダンティー アユワノー スカンバラン
はい ではどうもありがとうございました